recently a contest was launched for
those interested in making math physics
explainer videos it's essentially the
physics version of three blue one Browns
contest and Brilliant has come on board
to divvy 5000 USD equally among the top
five the details are linked below this
will be a lengthy introduction as there
are several announcements that I've been
holding on to and I can finally
publicize them as usual you can click on
the timestamp over here or in the
description to skip this longish preface
firstly you should know about today's
guest and that is Professor of Harvard
Avi Loeb now obvious an astrophysicist
and a cosmologist with such a multitude
of accolades that I could barely I can't
memorize them so I'm simply going to
read them so for one he's the longest
serving chair of Harvard's Department of
astronomy he's the founding director of
Harvard's black hole initiative he's the
director of The Institute for Theory and
computation he's a fellow at the
American Academy of Arts and Science and
the American physical society and the
international academy for astronautics
he's the science Theory director for the
Breakthrough initiatives of the
Breakthrough prize foundation and again
he's won so many awards that I'll just
list them on screen in the past year or
so avi's headed What's called the
Galileo project which is dedicated to
the systematic scientific search for
evidence of extraterrestrial
technological artifacts we're also
announcing here that the Galileo project
will have its first results in the
summer of 2023. today we talk about
Consciousness God uaps and the problem
with current theoretical physics you
should know that I've spoken to Avi lope
one year ago on this channel asking him
about wormholes and the physics that Bob
Lazar suggests Propel the UFO craft link
to that podcast is in the description
for those of you who are unfamiliar my
name is Kurt J mungle I'm a torontonian
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything mainly from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing and exploring what the
heck is consciousness and what is its
role related to fundamental laws if
fundamental laws even exist exist in the
sense that there's a bottom to it
perhaps reductionism isn't the correct
Paradigm but regardless you now have a
flavor of what this podcast is about now
on to some announcements the URL
theories of
everything.org is active the reasons for
which I'll get to shortly one of the
advantages is that I'm going to be
announcing what are the upcoming guests
to members there either first or at
least simultaneously as I don't like to
provide many exclusives so for example
Salvatore Pius is coming on the theories
of everything podcast in the middle of
October he will be joined with
theoretical physicist Stefan Alexander
now both Stefan and salvatarpais have
been on the podcast before Stefan
specializes he's one of the few that's
an expert in both Loop quantum gravity
and string theory in the previous
podcast with Stefan we talk about String
Theory particularly a new Theory of
Everything called the autodidactic
universe which is a universe that learns
its own laws that will be in the
description as for Salvatore Pious he
has only given one interview and that's
luckily been on theories of everything
that will be in the description as well
and it's about quantum gravity for those
of you who don't know Salvatore Pious is
the man who's behind the UFO patents
also coming up is Ian mcgilchrist and
John vervaki being joined as a
theolocution again John has been on the
theories of everything podcast before
solo and that will be in the description
as well as Ian mcgilchrist in fact the
one with Ian is one of the highest
quality podcasts on toe okay now let's
talk about the website so
theoriesofeverything.org is a place
where you can go to support toe because
many people choose to not support the
platform of patreon because of at least
reportedly there's some unscrupulous
business practices or at least
questionable what their future is so
that's one reason and secondly patreon
takes a huge cut many people don't know
this but their credit card transaction
fees Plus patreon on top of that takes a
percentage
theoriesofeverything.org is a vehicle
that I have control over so if you like
you can donate there directly as I
imagine the reason you're supporting toe
is to support toe not to support Kurt
Plus patreon there are also several
benefits to being a member on the
website number one you'll get an ads
free audio version keep in mind that all
ads whether they're in the introduction
or in the middle those are called
mid-rolls they're skippable by clicking
on the next time stamp I ensure this
because I'm the one that time stamps
each episode regardless if you'd like an
ad free audio version that comes to you
as a benefit for being a member on the
theories of everything.org website
additionally the way that it works on
toe's end is that I render out an
episode and then I wait approximately
two days or so between once it's
uploaded to YouTube and once it finally
premieres and one of the reasons for
that is to build an audience Etc however
what that means is that I actually have
the episode completed 12 to 48 hours
prior to you seeing it so what will
happen is if you're a member you'll get
an uploaded ads free version 12 to 48
hours before anyone else again nothing
changes for those of you who are on
YouTube and want to stay there and don't
want to be a toll member Etc that's fine
it's the same way that it's been
nothing's going to change there another
benefit of being a member on the website
rather than on patreon or any other
platform is that there will be discounts
or even free tickets offered whenever we
have Live Events additionally okay this
is another benefit you'll get a
personalized number to text me if you
like that yes this goes to my phone it's
not someone else answering for instance
you can say Kurt you said that so-and-so
episode was coming out I was wondering
what the progress is on that Kurt have
you seen the finale of Better Call Saul
Kurt when you're going to be speaking to
Stephen Greer by the way Stephen Greer
will be coming on the tow podcast
mid-october the specific date is not
here yet and there's a high likelihood
that it will be live and that's whether
you remember or not it's going to be
live on YouTube public another benefit
to being a member on the website is that
if you have Ama questions to ask for
myself my amas that is the questions and
answers with Kurt and then you can
submit them there and I'll be doing amas
for the members keep in mind that if you
have a question for example Greer or
Salvador Pious or any other guest there
is no exclusive to being a member or to
being on patreon or to being on Twitter
a quality question is a quality question
wherever it comes from I don't
prioritize questions based on if someone
donates let's say two hundred dollars in
a super chat or if they donate zero
they're just simply asking a question
like anyone else there are no plans for
the live streams to be member specific
though if I ever do an in-person meeting
like for example I'm thinking of filming
with an audience and Carl friston in
person in London then that may be
streamed to website members another
benefit is that certain merch will be
exclusive to being a member so for
example one that I'm working on now is a
notebook where at the top of each page
is a quotation from a different
mathematician or a physicist or even a
spiritual leader and that will hopefully
serve as inspiration for whatever you're
writing on the page okay so there are
manifold benefits to being a
theoriesofeverything.org remember don't
go to theoriesofeverything.com some
cyber squatters has that domain so dot
org toe is supported by you and the
sponsors thank you thank you so much I
wouldn't be able to do toe without you
whether it's full-time or part-time
wouldn't be able to do this without you
there are so many many plans for the
future again I wouldn't be able to do it
without you so thank you thank you
whether you're just watching or whether
you donate that's it okay now on to the
sponsors if you're familiar with toe
you're familiar with brilliant but for
those who don't know Brilliance is a
place where you go to learn math science
and engineering through these bite-sized
Interactive Learning experiences for
example and I keep saying this I would
like to do a podcast on information
Theory particularly Chiara marleto which
is David Deutsch's student has a theory
of everything that she puts forward
called Constructor Theory which is
heavily contingent on information Theory
so I took their course on random
variable distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take Brilliance course it was the
first time that I could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive formula
that is to say that it would be
unnatural to Define it in any other
Center visit brilliant.org toe that is
t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and I recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons I think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking at some point I'll also go
through the courses and give a
recommendation in order okay wow thank
you for sitting through that prodigious
introduction now on to the episode with
Avi Loeb enjoy thank you for coming out
Avi
thanks for having me it's a great
pleasure
let's just lay some groundwork for the
audience who's unacquainted with you
what is the Galileo project and what has
it been up to in the past year
the Galileo project is called after
Galileo Galilei that uh a physicist that
founded modern science four centuries
ago he was put in house arrest because
he suggested that maybe the Earth is not
at the center of the universe and at the
time people thought that it is and the
philosophers
uh said that that makes no sense we
don't even want to look through our
telescopes and The Innovation that he
brought forward is that we should look
for evidence before we assert something
rather than just make a statement
because it flatters our ego and today he
would have been canceled on social media
because his view was not popular at the
time but if you were to ask those
philosophers to design a space mission
that would reach Mars they would never
get to their destination because they
thought that Mars moves around the Earth
so in the Galileo project four centuries
later we say we learned something
important from Galileo which is let's
look for evidence to guide us rather
than Prejudice and we apply it in the
context of
is there a smart intelligent neighbor in
our Cosmic
neighborhood you know in our uh our
Cosmic backyard and
um and then in the past people had very
strong opinions on this and people also
after we developed radio communication
people said oh let's look for radio
signals but you know it's quite
narrow-minded to think that just because
we just develop radio communication that
will be the main uh Way by which we will
detect extraterrestrial civilization
because we ourselves are moving away
from radio right now we have the cable
and fiber optics and in space we are
developing
laser communication so why would you
assume that such a communication method
applies for more than a century or two
for any advanced civilization and so um
it's just like trying to say let's have
a phone conversation with wolfgangama
Deus Mozart and you will never find
Mozart if you try to dial all the phone
numbers available level because he died
and so to have a radio signal
approaching us now would imply that
there is someone transmitting just at
the time that we're listening which is
probably not the case because most stars
from billions of years before the Sun so
they're radius any radio signal from
there is billions of light years away
anyway so the approach we are taking
within the gorilla project is to search
for relics because we sent out five
spacecraft over half a century which is
pretty much one part in 100 million of
the age of the Earth just over that
short period of time we send five
spacecraft that will leave the solar
system and uh it's quite likely that if
there was another Advanced civilization
a billion years ago they sent some
equipment out of their planetary system
and if they were more advanced than we
are then you know they could have sent
probes that after a billion years fill
up the entire Milky Way galaxy because
if they are self-replicating if they
have 3D printers you know if they have
artificial intelligence so that they can
continue to be functioning for a long
period of time then they might as well
fill up all the habitable regions around
stars in the Milky Way so we say you
know if you launch systems with chemical
Rockets they will remain gravitationally
bound to the Milky Way they cannot
Escape like light signals radio signals
leave the Milky Way and they're gone
forever however if you send equipment
that tens of kilometers per second the
way we sent our spacecraft they will
still be bound gravitationally they
cannot escape from the Milky Way galaxy
so you think of the Milky Way galaxy as
a basket collecting all the pieces of
equipment all the devices that were ever
created since the Big Bang
within this volume
um and and were launched by chemical
Rockets or things that are not faster
than uh hundreds of kilometers per
second all of these things are now
sitting inside the Milky Way galaxy and
some of them may be functional some of
them may be space trash but we should
look around us to look for those objects
okay so that's I call that Interstellar
archeology
it's just like doing archeology finding
relics of things that existed in the
past the whoever produced them need not
be alive anymore that those
civilizations may be dead by now maybe
they didn't take care of their climate
maybe they went into a nuclear war you
know we don't care as long as they
launch things out of their planet that
could reach us by now we just search
around for anything they left and then
this intestinal archeology is something
that was never pursued despite 70 years
of City activity so if you ask how does
the City Community regard this endeavor
they dismiss it they ridiculate they say
no no no way this is ridiculous there is
nothing around us and I you know I say
well let's look because
only over the past five years we
discovered the first
three Interstellar objects objects that
came from outside the solar system in
astronomy astronomers the first one was
actually from 2014 and we will talk more
about it
cneos yes
January 8th 2014 a meteor that collided
with the Earth you can think of the
Earth as a fishing net that collab
collects objects along its path around
the sun and the first one identified by
government sensors
with a very high speed that indicated
that it came from outside the sources it
was was found in 2014 and nobody paid
attention to it until in 2019 I was
interviewed on the radio and about
meteors and I I looked online and I
found this catalog of meteors the
government compiled based on Missile
Warning Systems data and I asked my
student Amir siraj to check if the
fastest moving meteors could have been
Unbound to the sun okay any of them
could have come from outside the solar
system and we found that we found that
one okay and we wrote a paper and then
the reviewers of the paper said we don't
believe the US government you know we we
don't believe the uncertainties so then
it took it took a few years uh and uh I
got the people
um you know behind the National Security
Fence especially from the White House
from Department of Defense they issued a
letter from the U.S space command to
NASA confirming that indeed this object
that we identified with my student came
from outside the solar system at the
99.99 confidence okay so that's that's
the first Interstellar object it's the
first Interstellar meteor the size of a
basketball
um that was identified uh by humans okay
and the second one was identified in
2017 that was that my book
extraterrestrial talks about and the
third one was a comet just just like any
other Comet it came from outside the
solar system but the first two are
complete outliers uh the meteor has
material strength tougher than iron
tougher than all other meteors in the
catalog 273 of them by a factor of two
or more how do you measure toughness by
the way oh it's very easy because when
it collides with the Earth it basically
goes through the atmosphere and the
atmosphere gets denser as you go to
lower and lower in the atmosphere so the
density of the atmosphere gets diluted
As you move up and so you can we can
tell where the explosion took place it
was 18.7 kilometers above the ocean
surface 100 miles off the the coast of
Papua New Guinea that's where the
government identified the fireball that
was created from the object burning up
in the atmosphere and it released a few
percent of the energy
of the Hiroshima atomic bomb okay when
it exploded so from that you can you can
measure the speed of the object by how
fast this Fireball was moving at the
time that the explosion took place it's
a ball of light and it's a very
different detection method then looking
at which was just reflection of sunlight
so muamua was roughly the size of a
football field in order for us to see it
and this one was half a meter you know
like 200 times smaller and the reason we
could see an object so small half a
meter in size is because it burned up It
produced its own light and so you can
tell the speed by which it was moving
which was 45 kilometers per second and
you can tell the density of the
atmosphere in its vicinity when it
exploded so you can tell how much stress
was exerted on this object when it
disintegrated so prior to that it was at
lower density of air it didn't
disintegrate it held together but as it
got to a very dense environment
eventually disintegrated because the
stress the pressure acting on it was too
large for its material strength to
resist it so you can tell what is the
yield strength the material strength of
this object based on the you know it's
speed and the density of air when it
started disintegrating and it turns out
to be twice tougher than iron
and that's very unusual because iron
meteorites are only five percent of all
space rocks that hit the earth only five
percent and this was
two times tougher than iron just think
about it and moreover if we go back in
time it actually moved faster than 95
percent of all the stars in the vicinity
of the Sun so it was an outlier both in
terms of its speed and in terms of its
composition and I say you know if it's
such an outlier
you know faster than 95 percent of the
stars in the vicinity of the sun and the
moving and having material strength
tougher than iron tougher than all the
other meteors in the catalog we better
check whether it's an artifact whether
it's artificially made and the way to
check is to collect the fragments from
the ocean floor and and check their
composition whether it's an alloy that
was artificially produced or whether
it's an iron meteorite produced by
nature but even if it's iron it it's
rare it's unusual and the question
arises why the first meteor is of that
composition so anyway this was an
outlier definitely omuamua was an
outlier for a completely different
reason it was flat in shape based on the
reflection of sunlight that was
published as a scientific paper not by
me by someone actually the first
discovery paper argued that it's flat
most likely pancake shaped the first
discovery paper quick message from a
sponsor when I do eat meat I care about
the source of it both in terms of the
quality of the food itself and about the
standards that the place has with regard
to animal welfare and Humane Animal
treatment butcherbox takes the guesswork
out of finding high quality Meat and
seafood that you can trust given its 100
grass-fed beef free-range chicken pork
raised crate free and wild caught
Seafood they're humanely raised no
antibiotics no added hormones given that
I'm a hermit one of my favorite features
is that it's delivered straight to you
straight to your door if you're in the
US you get free shipping convenience
with no surprise fees the search for
outstanding deals on high quality
protein ends here butcher box is offer
until listeners free New York strips and
lobster so you can bring that Steakhouse
quality to your house sign up today at
butcherbox.com theories and get two 10
ounce New York strip steaks and eight
ounces of Lobster Claw and knuckle meat
free in your first order again that's
butcherbox.com theory is to claim this
deal and then when I started suggesting
that it may be artificial then people
backed off and said no no no it's just a
Flat Rock you know but then it turns out
it's not a comet because there was no
commentary tale it was pushed away from
the Sun despite the fact that there was
no rocket effect from commentary tale it
came from a special frame of reference
all kinds of weird properties can you
explain that last part that it came from
a special frame of reference yeah so
there is this local stand up of rest
which is the frame that you get to when
you average over the random motions of
the stars in the vicinity of the Sun
it's sort of like the you can think of
it as the local parking lot the galactic
frame of reference and stars move
relative to it because stars get kicks
when they are born they are not born
exactly at the frame of the Galaxy they
are born in some Cloud that is moving
right into that frame uh or they get
kicked afterwards so they develop a
characteristic speed of 20 30 kilometers
per second relative to the local
standard of rest but you can take the
average of the local stars and just get
that frame of reference okay so some
stars are moving to the right some sums
to the left and you take the average you
get to that frame of reference now turns
out that was at rest in the local
standard of rest
and only one part one part in a in 500
of all stars are so much at rest in that
frame as
so you ask yourself
you know what's the chance that it came
from a star it's one in 500.
so that was very unusual about it then
you ask what's the chance that it's flat
you know we don't see objects that are
10 times longer than they are thick and
they're flat we don't see rocks like
that very you know we don't see such
things at most it's factor of three
between the long axis and the short axis
and here it was at least 10 times longer
than it was wide projected on the sky
based on the variation of reflected
sunlight and then it didn't have a
cometary tail but it was pushed away
from the Sun so I suggest that it's a
thin object just like a light sail or
you know a surface layer of a you know a
spacecraft that was torn apart or you
know something artificial because we've
never seen anything like it and then
people said no way you know the
mainstream of astronomy there was a
paper in nature magazine nature
astronomy magazine a review paper saying
is natural period explanation
exclamation mark it's natural that's it
there is no reason to consider other
Alternatives and then a few months later
there was a paper by a group of people
saying actually to explain the
properties of a muamua like it was
pushed away from the Sun maybe we need a
cloud of dust particles like a Dust
Bunny that is a hundred times less dense
than air and it reflects sunlight
therefore it's being pushed it's very
lightweight a hundred times less dense
than air and here the problem is if it
comes close to the sun such a cloud of
dust particles will get heated by
hundreds of degrees will not maintain
its Integrity okay so then another team
a few months later and just to remind
you all of this happened after the
people who were on the review paper
declared it must be natural period let's
not discuss it anymore so then other
groups of mainstream astronomers said
yeah yeah it is natural but it has to be
a Dust Bunny no no that doesn't make
sense okay so it has to be a hydrogen
Iceberg a chunk of Frozen hydrogen so
that when it evaporates just like a
comet we can't see the hydrogen because
it's transparent and therefore it is a
comet but a comet made of material that
we can't see when it evaporates uh so
the problem with that is hydrogen
evaporates very easily so it will not
survive the journey we wrote a
scientific paper about it with my
colleague Sim Juan so the people who
advocated for hydrogen Iceberg said yes
that's correct there is a problem here
it wouldn't survive very long distances
in interstellar space so then another
thing came along and said oh yeah now we
have the answer it's a nitrogen Iceberg
so everyone's cheered and said yeah yeah
yeah nitrogen Iceberg why nitrogen
nitrogen is transparent so just like
hydrogen evaporates hydrogen can
evaporate where do you find chunks of
Frozen nitrogen well the surface of
Pluto has solid nitrogen so maybe there
are all these EXO Pluto's out there and
they get bombarded all the time by rocks
and then you get chips of those surfaces
and those chips are representing of the
population of objects like okay the
problem with that we showed with in the
paper with my student there is just not
enough material in solid hydrogen to a
in solid nitrogen to explain a large
enough population such that you would
see a more so it just doesn't work out
the mass budget so I say there are
problems with each of these mainstream
explanations but moreover each of them
advocates for something that we've never
seen before so how can you say it must
be natural period explain exclamation
mark
in a review paper and then come back and
say ah yeah yeah it was this that or
that things that we've never seen before
if it was obvious that it's natural you
wouldn't need to come up with these
three explanations as published papers
these are not just people proposing it
on a blog or on Twitter these are real
papers that took months for people to
write and each of these invokes
something we've never seen before each
of them has problems and I say if it's
something we've never seen before we
should live on the table the possibility
that's artificial
but no that is completely moved out of
the table and I say well that's not the
scientific process the scientific
process is collecting evidence so the
Galileo project one of the goals is
aside from the expedition to scoop the
ocean floor to look for the fragments of
of the first meteor the first
Interstellar meteor we are also planning
a rendezvous with the next omuamua so
that we can collect more evidence you
know just the way Galileo said you know
let's get data and if you are a
philosopher that knows the answer in
advance like natural then you say I
don't need any data but you are behaving
just like the philosophers during the
days of Galileo you don't want to look
for a telescope because you think you're
not the answer because you are jealous
of the attention it gets because of all
kinds of reasons I don't care what they
are because you are an expert that
worked on rocks all your life and you
want everything in the sky to be rocks
that's your problem we will try to
collect data and figure it out that's
the way science is done without
prejudice and if we take a high
resolution image of the next tomorrow
and see that it's a nitrogen Iceberg
stop it but let's first see you can't
say it must be natural until you see the
nitrogen Iceberg okay so
um the Galileo project is designing a
space mission and then it's sort of like
dating the next to muamua uh-huh yeah I
saw a blog post on that yeah so dating
you know we have a dating app which is
the Vera Rubin Observatory uh there is
the Legacy survey of space and time and
uh we'll start operations in a year in
Chile that's a a telescope that will
have a camera with 3.2 billion pixels
just think about it your cell phone has
a camera of a few million pixels here
I'm talking 3.2 billion so that's a
factor of a thousand more pixels in a
year on a telescope serving the southern
sky from Chile every four days it will
scan the entire sky so there is a high
likelihood that every few months it will
find another object like omomoa sort of
like a dating app we will look at the
data that comes from the pipeline of
this telescope which will be public
because it's funded by the National
Science Foundation yeah and most of the
time we will swipe to the left we will
say no this object is Not Unusual enough
but if it finds an Interstellar object
that is as weird as
we might want to invest a billion
dollars in sending a space mission that
will come close to it because you know a
picture is worth a thousand words and in
my case it's worth 66 000 words the
number of words in my book I would need
to write the book if we had a high
resolution image the other thing we have
is the web telescope the web telescope
is about a million miles away from Earth
and it offers a fantastic vantage point
because you look at the object let's say
the next from different directions you
look at it from Earth and you look at it
from the web telescope and then you can
trade it's just like having two eyes you
may ask why do we have two eyes we have
two eyes because then we get the third
dimension because one eye sees an object
that could be of a threat for our
survival you know sees an object from
One Direction and then the second die
sees it from another direction from that
you can gauge the distance and that
helps for survival that's why we have
two eyes all those people that existed
before us with one eye could not figure
out the distance and the tiger would eat
them okay so it was important for
survival to have two eyes but in the
context of the web telescope you know we
look at this object from the web
position which is a million miles away
and from Earth we can pinpoint the
trajectory in three dimensions of the
web telescope so we can figure out if
there are any forces other than gravity
acting on the object if it's propelled
by something other than gravity and if
there is no cometary tail you know maybe
it's something else and also the web
telescope can look at it in the infrared
and infer the composition so we will get
much more data in with the help of the
web telescope and then the third branch
just to finish the answer to your
question the third branch of the Galileo
project has to do with the report that
came out of the Director of National
Intelligence Avril Haynes to the U.S
Congress
a year ago in June on June the June
report yeah the June 2021 and that led
to the establishment of a new office in
government they used to refer to these
objects that they cannot identify as
unidentified aerial phenomena UAP and
now they're talking Congress just
established a new piece of legislation
that they would like to pass and they uh
suggest that these objects are also
transmedium they go from water to air to
space so you know it apparently there is
some classified data that leads them in
that direction but also NASA decided to
establish a a committee that will
evaluate whether scientific research
will be funded on these objects we are
already doing it with the Galileo
project so what happened was that when
this report was delivered to Congress
um I suggested to NASA because Bill
Nelson said scientists should get
engaged so I immediately contacted the
person under him Thomas
who is responsible for science at Nasa
and I said
that it will be my pleasure and
privilege to help NASA
uh and and make his boss happy and he
said why don't you send a white paper I
submitted a white paper suggesting a
research program
and I never heard back and then a year
later uh in June 2022 they
uh announced without me knowing that
they have a this this committee that so
that was uh triggered by this uh white
paper that they sent but um and now they
regard me as having a conflict of
interest because in the meantime you
know around the same time of June July
2021 a few multi-billionaires came to
the porch of my home they were inspired
by my book extraterrestrial and they
gave me three million dollars to
establish the Galileo project and so at
the end of exactly a month after the
odni report to Congress we announced the
Galileo project and the third branch of
the Galileo project is trying to build a
suite of instruments
uh it's already on the roof of the
Harvard College Observatory right now we
are testing it a suite of instruments
that take video of the sky in the
infrared the optical band audio band
and analyzes it with artificial
intelligence algorithms and we are
testing it in the coming months and
hopefully by 2023 we'll start collecting
data at places where there are reports
on these objects and then you know
that's the third branch of the Galileo
projects we're already doing this
research uh and we should see it's a
phishing Expedition we should see if we
find
natural objects only or maybe some
human-made objects natural or you know
like for example birds or bugs or
meteors or or Lightnings uh human-made
objects or drones airplanes satellites
and so weather balloons but the question
is whether there is something else and
on November 10th 2021 uh I was invited
to a forum The ignacio's Forum at the
Washington National Cathedral uh
together with Jeff Bezos Bill Nelson and
Avril Haynes the Director of National
Intelligence so when I was in The Green
Room with Avril Haynes I approached her
and said what do you think what is your
gut feeling about the nature of these
objects that you reported about because
she had a bachelor's degree in
theoretical physics from the University
of Chicago so you know she understands
my language as a physicist and I said
what what do you think they are and she
said I don't know
and I think frankly you know the
government the intelligence agencies
they are not a scientific organization
I think it's time for scientists to
engage because the sky is not classified
it's only the sensors that the
government is using that are classified
and that's why the data is classified so
the Galileo project will try to break
this open in the sense of you have all
these non-professional people reporting
about things where you know the images
are fuzzy there are anecdotal we don't
know the truth and and then you have the
classified data that we don't have
access to so the Galileo project will
try to establish a data stream that is
open to the public the way science is
done everyone will be able to access the
data and it will be of high quality we
will know exactly what our instruments
are doing unlike those cameras on the
jittery cockpits of of fighter jet
airplanes you know like we we don't know
exactly what they were doing at the time
so all of this is to bring the subject
to the mainstream of science because
because you know science should address
the main task of science is to address
questions that are of interest to
society are of interest to the
government and it's just it feels just
inappropriate that this subject is
ridiculed and pushed aside from the
mainstream of science
okay so let me see if I got this correct
there are three branches or three goals
in the near term for the Galileo project
so one is to go and look in the ocean
floor for that meteorite that you
mentioned initially so that's cneos I
believe in 2014. okay then you have the
the search for umuamua like objects and
that I believe you mentioned a Chilean
Observatory yes the Vera Rubin
Observatory yes okay okay so that's not
the Galileo projects that's what you
would rent out is that how it works well
this is yeah the dating app think about
it as it will suggest objects of
interest that came from outside the
solar system that we can follow up on
either by using existing telescopes to
look at them or sending a space mission
that will take a close-up photograph
okay and then also you would get some
other form of verification from the
James Webb Telescope now I don't know
how that works are you allowed to just
say hey James Webb Telescope people can
you tell me what you saw at this point
or do you tell them hey James Webb
Telescope people can you now look in
this direction like how does that work
do you have to rent it yeah actually
if okay if we announce the discovery of
an another Interstellar object
especially if it looks like or more in
terms of being weird
I will not need to do much because
immediately I mean usually there is some
discretionary time that belongs to the
director of the Space Telescope Science
Institute or other people have some time
that they will be happy to donate for
this because despite all of all you hear
from people who are not practitioners of
science you you see them writing tweets
or writing blogs basically very
aggressively attacking the possibility
that such an object is of interest and
saying oh it must be natural we've seen
a lot of these despite what they say
these are people that are not
professionals I think the scientific
Community once we find more objects of
this type it will be a very important
question to figure out their nature okay
because just think about it if there are
hydrogen icebergs you know those are not
produced in uh planetary systems that
are those are potentially produced in
molecular clouds we've never ever seen a
chunk of Frozen hydrogen produced by
Nature that would be a great discovery
we've never seen a chunk of Frozen
nitrogen in the solar system and the
claim is no no you will not find it in
the solar system because these chunks
were produced in the distant past and
none of them survived and therefore
there is nothing in the solar system but
what we find are chunks of Frozen
nitrogen coming into the solar system
from other planeters that's that's the
sort of popular idea by some people
right now for the origin of a moon okay
suppose we find that it's a nitrogen
aspect that would also be an important
Revelation because nobody expected it
before or more nobody okay and I say it
may not be either of them and it may not
be a Dust Bar even if okay suppose we
see it apart you know imagine those
clouds of dust particles floating around
and that would be a revelation it's
something completely new that we've
never expected so in any case it will be
a major Discovery and and therefore I
think that the the web telescope time
will be allocated almost instantly to
look at these things and I will you know
in the worst case I will apply for time
together with colleagues but I don't
think it will be necessary I think there
will be enough curious astronomers that
would like to figure out what these
things are and of course once we observe
a few of those then we would have a
better clue and you know whatever it is
it would be fun to figure it out and I
think uh even those that advocate for
natural origin would like to demonstrate
it with data so even though they are
biased you know it's just like taking
those philosophers at the time of
Galileo and telling them look through
the telescope you know we are not
telling you what you would see just look
through them they refuse to do that back
then but now I think we live at a
different time and once we have the data
from web that nobody can censor by the
way it's not as if you can put the
people that constructed the web in-house
arrest that is not the data will be
public no matter what so it will make no
sense to ignore the data so as long as
we look at it just to demonstrate that
the objects are natural that's okay they
can be they can think whatever they want
but eventually it will be clear if it's
if it's not natural you know so so I'm
saying I'm not saying all the objects
must be artificial you know it it will
be just like going on the beach you know
most of the time you find rocks and
seashells that are naturally produced
the solar system contains a lot of those
but every now and then you may bump into
a plastic bottle and that's you know
those outliers are what we should be
looking for and checking if they exist
okay so even if another object is found
and people think that it's natural it's
still abnormal and so they would have an
incentive to look for it because
nitrogen or a block of nitrogen a block
of hydrogen a block of a Dust Bunny of
some sort is aberrant exactly
I should tell you um that this is the
third phase of a three stage story uh
the story started about a century ago
okay uh around the
1925 that was when Cecilia Payne
kapashkin was a young scientist who
finished the wanted to have the first
PhD doctoral degree in astronomy at
Radcliffe Harvard back then the Harvard
what you know the the she was at the
Radcliffe uh Institute but then she
wanted to get a degree in astronomy uh
and that was not possible she was the
first one okay now her PhD back in
1925 okay was about the Sun
and that was just around after quantum
mechanics was invented and so forth and
she realized that based on the spectrum
of a mission from the Sun that the
surface of the Sun is made mostly of
hydrogen
now at the time people thought oh you
know we know what the earth is made of
so the sun is made of the same stuff as
the Earth
okay and that was the prevailing
Paradigm everyone believed in that so
she presented her thesis saying actually
it looks like the Sun at least the
surface of the Sun is made mostly of
hydrogen
and on her PhD thesis committee was the
most prominent uh astronomer at the time
that was an expert on Stars he was the
director of Princeton University
Observatory Henry Norris Russell okay
and he said to her
that's impossible
take this statement out of your thesis
it makes no sense to argue that the son
everyone knows that the sun has the same
composition as the Earth
so she was a young female scientist at
the time decided okay well if the expert
tells me that you know otherwise I might
not get a PhD she took it out he
dissuaded her and then for four years he
tried to analyze his own data and
published the paper four years later
saying that Cecilia was right
okay indeed the sun is made mostly of
hydrogen okay now the funny part of the
story and that's also an important
lesson is that about
um
80 years later
there was a visiting committee to the
Princeton University
Department of astrophysical Sciences
okay and
the chair of that department at
Princeton said we have a very
prestigious
history of the department
if you go back in time there was the
famous astronomer Henry Norris Russell
who discovered that the sun is made of
hydrogen
so then there was a member of that
committee uh
who corrected him and said look it's it
was not Henry Norris Russell it was
actually and he tried to argue otherwise
and the lesson of this story is that
history depends on who you are who
writes it
um but anyway so that's step one when we
realized we thought that we see things
in in our backyard here on Earth and
everything else like the sun is made of
the same stuff well mistake okay so a
young person named Cecilia pencopason
who later became the chair of the
astronomy Department of Public realized
it first then the second part of the
story is in 1933 about a decade later
Fritz Wiki young in his 30s realized
that groups are clusters of galaxies are
made mostly of stuff that we don't find
in the solar system he called it dark
matter
Okay so
for 40 years this subject was ridiculed
including by colleagues within his
department at Caltech
Pasadena where he was a professor he was
not his view was not popular people just
ridiculed it said doesn't make any sense
that most of the matter in the universe
is of a type that you don't find in the
solar system okay once again the same
story just like with Earth and the Sun
now it's we're talking about the
universe and the solar system the and by
now if you ask any student or postdoc
they would say of course no question
about it eighty percent 82 percent of
the matter in the universe is made of
stuff that is not ordinary matter that
you find in the source we don't we
haven't detected it yet we don't find it
in the solar system uh we don't know
what it is
uh it's dark matter okay we we just gave
it a label
so just again the lesson from this is
for 40 years this was ridicule until the
1970s
and now everyone says yes of course but
we still don't know what it is now I say
here is the third part of this story
over the past decade we found the first
objects that came from outside the solar
system just like going to your backyard
and thinking oh yeah anything I find in
my backyard so far I found from my
backyard was rocks therefore if
something comes from the street it will
also be a rock
but then you find the beach ball you
find a tennis ball you say no no no no
it's a rock of a type that we've never
seen before
and my point is just be open-minded
maybe you have a neighbor maybe these
objects are different than rocks why is
that such a a a an extraordinary claim
to say that other
exoplanets may have developed
intelligence the way Earth did and
resulted in spaceship or or some
equipment being thrown into space that
may visit us why is that so extra Runner
so my colleagues say extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
and I say in response and by the way
this is a quote of Carl Sagan from the
70s I say that makes no sense because
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy if you
say we don't need to everything is rocks
everything is natural that just the way
that this nature astronomy review paper
said it must be natural period
explanation mark let's forget about it
let's move on if you say that you don't
look for evidence if you don't admit
that the emperor has no claws if you
don't say that
then you don't even search you don't
check you say well it's a rock of some
type of a very unusual type forget about
it there are more important pressing
items like dark matter
but fundamentally it may be much more
important than dark matter because if we
find the dark matter is super symmetric
particles it will have zero impact on
our daily lives if we find that there is
a smarter kid on our block it will
change the future of humanity so I say
how can you ignore that possibility and
the point is that you know we should be
guided by evidence that's the key to uh
being humble being modest be saying you
know we don't know the answers let's
just figure them out let's allow nature
to educate us that's something else
that's important that I don't think is
talked about much that when someone
dismisses something because it's
quote-unquote improbable it's not simply
a probabilistic argument there's also a
value judgment there and the reason is
when I'm driving along a country road
and there's a hill I can't see the cars
that are coming up and let's say I've
passed 50 of them and there's no cars
it's empty I still slow down and the top
of the hill even though it's improbable
there's another car because it's
important that I don't hit someone or
that I don't get hit and so even if it's
improbable that it's life the importance
of it is so high that that needs to be
taken into account as well exactly
exactly that was the Pascal bless
Pascal's argument why we should discuss
the possibility of God because the
implications are so great
um and my point in response to Carl
Sagan's quote is that extraordinary
evidence requires extraordinary funding
and you know we invested billions of
dollars in the search for Dark Matter
over the past several decades the most
the most recent attempt was using the
Large Hadron Collider that cost 10
billion dollars to find the lightest
supersymmetric particle as a candidate
for the dark matter and people said you
know it will be found it's around the
corner string theory was established on
the foundation of supersymmetry and
there are some very natural set of
parameters for supersymmetry that
everyone believed in and awards were
given to people who suggested that and
so forth and then the Large Hadron
Collider at the cost of 10 billion
dollars didn't find it okay there is no
uh supersymmetry at the natural set of
parameters there was no Dark Matter
particle that we discovered so far okay
and I so I say you know if we were to
invest billions of dollars in the search
for equipment from other civilizations
in outer space and we would spend
billions of dollars for decades and not
find anything
then we would be exactly the same point
as dark matter searches are right now so
why didn't anyone say
supersymmetry is an extraordinary claim
there is no extraordinary evidence for
it
therefore we should not fund the search
why didn't anyone no it's legitimate to
search for Supercenter because there was
a community that agreed that it's a good
idea okay so we invested the billions of
dollars we didn't find it does anyone
take responsibility for that no people
say well that's the nature of science
you imagine something you don't find it
so now why do we block funding
for something that we as a civilization
already did in terms of sending
equipment out of the solar system why do
we block funding for the search for
something similar that was initiated by
a duplicate of ourselves because you
know the the dice was rolled tens of
billions of times in the Milky Way
galaxy the dice of intelligence we know
that somewhere between a few percent to
a hundred percent of all the sun-like
stars have a planet the size of the
Earth roughly the same separation that's
from the Kepler satellite we already
know that so what we find in the solar
system is not an extremely rare
situation and I say okay you roll the
dice of intelligence so many times tens
of business it's quite possible and most
stars form billions of years before the
sun we should allow for this possibility
to me it doesn't sound more far-fetched
or more speculative then the lightest
supersymmetric particle being the
darkness better okay but on that front
we invested billions of dollars in the
search for the lightest supersymmetric
part on the front of searching for what
we are doing from another kid on our
Cosmic block we didn't spend anything
from federal funding so the Galileo
project is funded by private donations
and we haven't really engaged
scientifically in that search so I say
there is a mismatch between the current
academic approach to this subject and
moreover you may say oh um scientists
are conservative I say how it how is
that possible to imagine that scientists
are conservative because you have a
whole community of theoretical
physicists that for four decades are
working on extra dimensions
on the Multiverse on string theory ideas
that have no
foundation in experimental verification
there is no evidence for those ideas yet
they are part of the mainstream
and on the other hand we have some
evidence that we exist as an intelligent
species we have evidence that we send
out equipment that will exit the solar
system we have evidence that a planet
like the Earth around the star like the
sun is very common you know it's
that are billions if not tens of
billions of such planets in the Milky
Way galaxy alone
and many of these stars from billions of
years before the sun
so how can we even argue that this is a
very speculative idea to imagine that we
are not that Albert Einstein was not the
smartest scientist that ever existed
since the big bang I mean that makes no
sense it's very likely that there was a
scientist smarter than Albert Einstein
that lived a billion years ago on an
exoplanet and the civilization who
benefited from the discoveries of that
scientist may have sent probes that fill
up the Milky Way galaxy
and may populate the habitable zones of
many stars by now furthermore there's
the simulation hypothesis which
presupposes something like another
intelligent life why is it that certain
mainstream ideas like you mentioned
extra dimensions and many worlds and
even simulation and so on is the
simulation is more philosophical than it
is physics-based but why is it that
these ideas are taken more seriously
however the idea is that there's
extraterrestrial intelligent life that
has visited us whether or not it exists
I think main many or perhaps most
scientists would say yes but whether or
not they've visited us or continue to
visit us to this day is something
different why do you think that is why
do you think that they don't like that
idea it's clearly because there's a
stigma so why why is that stigma there
yeah it's this the answer is very simple
humans enjoy ideas that flatter their
ego
okay so if the idea says we are at the
center of the universe
that's great we can adapt it for a
thousand years we can put Galileo in
house arrest
and refuse to look at the evidence why
because it flatters our ego to think
that we are at the center of the
universe
that God
considers US Special unique and
privileged
okay so then
you find evidence after a while even
though you lock Galileo eventually it
turns out that we are not at the center
of the universe eventually it turns out
that we came to the cosmic stage just at
the end
so if you come to a play you know 13.8
billion years after the cosmic Place
started just at the end and you are not
at the center of the stage then guess
what you are not a primary actor okay
and you better search for other actors
to tell you what the play is about okay
but that goes against the human ego
that's not flattering so what do you do
you say okay I'm not at the center of
the play but there are no other actors
therefore I am important despite
everything
and I am the smartest now I can
understand that approach because when my
daughters were young they were at home
and they thought that they are the
smartest in the world until we took them
to the kindergarten and on the first day
in the kindergarten
they had a psychological shock to
realize that there is a smarter kid in
their neighborhood now I say how can you
avoid going to the kindergarten very
easily you just ridicule on social media
any possible intriguing evidence that
that's not the case the way the way the
philosophers behaved at the time of
Galileo you hope that nobody else will
pay attention to Galileo why because you
put him in a house arrest so that nobody
can listen you don't look through the
telescope and you suppress the
information as much as you can and you
say there is nothing there
forget about it exclamation mark period
forget about it you say that you put him
in house arrest or nobody would listen
you think that would cure the threat to
your ego but it doesn't because
eventually someone else finds the
evidence and reality is whatever it is
if you were to ask those philosophers to
design a space mission that would reach
Mars they would never get to their
destination because they thought that
Mars moves around the Earth but reality
is not like that you know you can launch
a spacecraft and it will never reach a
destination if you have the wrong ideas
so by today's standards what Galileo
said was trivial because you can look at
the Earth from a distance you can go to
Mars and you realize Galileo was right
okay there is no way this philosophers
were right you know that okay but for a
while they were able to dominate public
opinion to be popular and to maintain
their grip on the false notion of
reality so that's that's a tendency
that's a the ability of humans to
basically go on Twitter and make a lot
of noise about something that they don't
like now it may work in politics you
know in politics things are you know you
don't have hard facts sometimes so you
can argue whatever you want you can get
a lot of likes and you feel good about
yourself but in science what Galileo
taught us is if you want to adapt to
reality you better pay attention to
evidence so I say when there is
something intriguing that doesn't line
up with what you expected your duty as a
scientist is to collect more evidence
your duty is to say well maybe the
emperor has no clothes maybe what we
think is incorrect and the only way to
find out is to admit that possibility to
admit a possibility that the Dark Matter
may not be weekly interacting massive
particle because if you do fund the
Large Hadron Collider and it doesn't
find it you know that your previous
notion was incorrect that's the way
science makes progress it checks
possibilities by looking for evidence
and if you on the other hand say you
know the answer in advance you may be
just like those philosophers just to
give you an example this experience
addition to Papua New Guinea gained a
lot of traction recently because the NBC
had a beautiful video about it
and the NPR reported about it
and then
as soon as the NPR story broke out just
yesterday it broke out for the second
time some people had negative things
they injected poison into the discussion
by saying some people yeah some people
and many of them are not practicing
astronomers
um and so I I don't want even to get
into the issue of what their
qualifications are
uh but the point of the matter is
you know this Expedition is funded from
donations it's done by a team of
scientists and all we are doing is going
to a place where a meteor disintegrated
and trying to check what the fragments
are made of like why would that bother
anyone why would anyone resist that
other than the Instinct that the
philosophers had at the time of Galileo
what I'm trying to say is four centuries
later we still see the same phenomenon
where people
with very strong conviction
oppose the Gathering of evidence and
data and why are we going to Papua New
Guinea why because this object was
tougher than iron there is evidence for
that because the government measured the
properties of the meteor and it looks
like it came from outside the solar
system so it was an outlier that's all
so it's all guided you know I didn't
dream this object at night it was not a
subject of a science fiction story it
was evidence the government provided
that allows you using the laws of
physics to figure out that this is an
outlier okay that came from outside the
service that's all it motivates us to
examine what its composition is so why
wouldn't everyone cheer up and say great
let's figure out what this object is
let's find more evidence why would it
bother people that this is happening and
the only way I can see it is first
jealousy that this project gets
attention Okay so whenever there is a
flower blooming above the grass level
people try to step on the flower because
it bothers them that there is something
different Rising above the grass level
they would rather see only grass okay so
that's one tendency that out of jealousy
they don't like the fact that there is a
flower blooming above the grass level
okay so whenever there is a flower they
would step on it so that's a reason for
toxicity you know like in social media
but as second thing is Prejudice and we
don't you know people find it uh
offending offensive to consider the
possibility that we are not the smartest
kid on the cosmic block it really
bothers me because you know just imagine
that imagine that we see the 100th
version of the iPhone coming from space
and it does magic
sort of like a cave dweller finding a
cell phone or going to New York City and
seeing all the gadgets there the cave
dweller would never be able to reverse
engineer these things it would look like
magic but it would be a blow to the ego
of the cave dweller who is used to
hunting animals or playing with rocks so
obviously if the cave dweller finds a
cell phone the first impression would be
oh it's a rock of a type that I've never
seen before
is a rock of a type that we've never
seen so that's the first impression
because you're used to a vocabulary that
you know you play with rocks all your
life this is a rock of a type that I've
never seen before but then you start
realizing that this gadget does things
that The Rock doesn't like if you press
a button it records your voice or
records your image so then it will
change your perception and eventually
you would realize there is Magic here
that something that goes beyond what I
was able to accomplish in my life of
hunting and Gathering okay so the cave
dweller we realize that and for us the
way to realize it is that we will figure
out that something is not natural
doesn't look like the compositions of a
natural object
or that it behaves in ways that go
beyond our Technologies okay so I say we
can follow the same learning
exercise we can
by getting more evidence we can get out
of our comfort zone but most people
prefer to stay in their comfort zone
just like the philosophers prefer to
stay in their comfort zone of us being
at the center of the world
I see those as the same the first one
which is the flower that stands above
the grass and wanting to stomp it out
out of jealousy and then the second one
out of wanting to be the most brightest
kid on the Block because both point out
one's own insufficiencies as far as one
thinks that it's all it's almost a view
of oneself if I was to correct or if one
was to correct although I'm speaking to
myself my own
insecurities and my own lowly view of
myself then I wouldn't be so
quick to criticize others and also maybe
see that something else being
more
valuable means that I can use that as an
aim so I can see it as a positive rather
than a a detriment that it doesn't shine
such a Negative light on me or shine no
light because all the spotlight is
elsewhere yeah there is a there is a
simple remedy to that and let me just
mention what is the solution the
solution is to look at kids
because kids don't know much about the
world okay so they learn from experience
so if they see an object they go and
check it
and an adult would sit and say oh I know
what this object is forget about but a
kid would go there and a kid often take
takes risks in this learning process you
know because they are not doing any
calculations about what the risk might
involve and what kind of danger might be
there and so forth so they they are much
more Innovative in the way they explore
the world they go to the object and
touch it and they move it around and
they play with it and you know the
advantage of this approach is that you
may discover something that you didn't
expect whereas if you think that you are
the expert that you know everything that
you will find based on your past
knowledge and if you pretend to have uh
the image of an adult you know uh where
you you know everything and you you
never show weaknesses as being
unfamiliar with something then you lose
the the edge of finding new things okay
discovering new things so the remedy to
the problems we discussed before is to
behave more like kids you know when I
see adults very often I I try to figure
out how what is the kid behind this
adult because we all pretend to be much
more than we actually are and
fundamentally you know if you look at
what we know and what we don't know
about the universe we are still like
classmates in the first day of class
there is so much we don't know you know
so many scientists got Awards just for
what you may regard as accounting you
know they just account for how much dark
matter there is in the universe how much
dark energy there is in the universe but
we still don't know what it is you're
just saying okay there is you know a
certain 25 percent uh of the cosmic Mass
budget is dark matter five percent is
ordinary matter 70 is dark dark energy
okay it sounds very impressive and a lot
of awards and prices are given to the
people who pinpoint the exact uh
accounting but we still don't know the
substance okay so there is so much we
don't know and we should be humble it's
a sense of humility you see uh the
exploration of the unknown is just like
spirituality you know you are exploring
something bigger than you so you should
not put yourself
up front that's what our ego wants to do
to put yourself as the center point but
if you know that you're in a a learning
experience like a kid if you just say I
don't know much I just want to figure it
out if that is the attitude rather than
say I know a lot and I want to portray
an image so that I will get more uh
honors and awards and more recognition
and so forth the way adults do their
calculations they portray an image that
they know much more than they actually
know if you do that then you are missing
the opportunity of discovering the truth
and a kid on the other hand admits you
know the kid doesn't know much and
therefore you know the kid takes risks
that the kid admits when things are not
clear so if we adapt that approach to
doing science I think there is the the
rate by which we make discoveries will
be accelerated and there is a simple
reason for that that the intellectual
climate will not be be about
demonstrating how smart you are but will
be about demonstrating what
what we learn you know and and and it's
a different task because you can
demonstrate that you are smart by asking
a question of
how many angels can dance on the tip of
a pin okay that sounds like a
fascinating question we don't know if
angels exist and whether they dance on
the tip of a pin but you can ask this
question Suppose there are angels and
they dance on the tip of a pin how many
can do it and then you can say okay let
me generalize this equation in 10
dimensions and do the calculation in 10
dimensions and develop your very
sophisticated math and people say wow
wow that's amazing how was that possible
to solve the equations of angels dancing
on the tip of opinion 10 Dimension
that's really exciting and then they
would say oh yeah but actually this is
not completely you know uh undeserving
the fact that we dedicated decades to
asking this question because we can use
the mathematics to solve that question
we can use it in the context of
understanding uh Quantum chromodynamics
you know like the the uh we can apply to
qcd uh to to the study of nuclei okay so
you develop some mathematics for one
question you say oh now I can use that
mathematics for another question well I
say that's that's legitimate that's
that's good but that's not the work of a
physicist now physicist is supposed to
ask questions that have to do with
reality and the way you learn about
reality is by experiments and not by
intellectual gymnastics and the reason
that you can be engaged just in
intellectual gymnastics without any
contact with reality is if the
motivation to show that you are smart
that if that is the motivation then you
don't care about experiments and and
that unfortunately is much much more
prevalent right now in the theoretical
physics Community showing that you are
smart and doing mathematical gymnastics
and I say you know that's a distraction
from the main
uh objective of physics which is to
describe reality and why is that
important to understand reality because
we live in that reality and we have to
adapt to it okay so in order to adapt to
reality we need to understand it we need
to know what environment we live in you
know we need to know if there is climate
change so that we can develop policy for
that we need to know if the Earth moves
around the Sun or the sun moves around
the Earth in order to develop spaceship
that will go into space in the right
direction and remove correctly so all of
these if we want to cure diseases if we
want to cure the pandemic you know we
need to understand how viruses operate
and develop an mRNA vaccine for them so
all of this has to do with us
figuring out what reality is and
adapting to it and it's irresponsible of
us to pursue a different goal which is
to elevate our ego to boost our ego to
brag in our intellectual gymnastics
because that may have nothing to do with
the reality that we're trying to
understand as physicists okay I have
many technical questions so but let me
just briefly get to one comment so would
you be okay then if theoretical
physicists change their name from
theoretical physicists to Pure
mathematicians oh yeah it could still be
a problem it's purely a categorization
problem no problem whatsoever you know
if a plumber comes to my home okay and
says I'm a plumber then I would ask the
plumber to fix the toilet
now suppose the plumber will tell me no
that's too difficult of a task I cannot
do it so I would say okay can you fix my
faucet you know it's not working and the
plumber would say oh that's also too
difficult then I would say you're not a
plumber so I I asked string theories I
say okay you are working on the
unification of quantum mechanics and
gravity I have two problems for you just
like the toilet and the and the faucet
one problem is uh what happened around
the big bag can you tell me and they say
no that's too difficult we can't really
solve that problem
so I said okay forget about the Big Bang
let's discuss the singularity at the
center of a black hole we know that we
need quantum mechanics and gravity for
that can you solve that problem and they
say no it's too difficult
so I say okay well so change your job
definition Because unless you solve
problems
you cannot call yourself a physicist
problems about objects in reality like
the big bang we know you know the
universe started from a hot dense phase
and if you use Einstein's equations you
get to a singularity so curing that
Singularity is a fundamental question
that currently we don't
have a solution too because you know we
don't have a quantum theory of gravity
but if string theory is you should first
offer the solution before claiming that
you're solving Quantum grab okay and the
same about singularities of black holes
so all I'm saying is the job definition
matters because people get paid to be
clamorous you see you can't just say
that you're
not
yeah
okay I understand also there's this
claim that hey in pure physics oh sorry
not pure physics and theoretical physics
and pure math that eventually today's
abstractions are tomorrow's applied for
example in string theory there's plenty
of applications to condensed matter
physics however and that comes about
decades later or so however I find that
to be a dubious claim and the reason is
that if you look at what's applied now
it almost certainly has a theoretical
origin but if you look at the totality
of theoretical work it's not as if all
of it's applied like I haven't seen an
analysis done on string theory let's say
let's look at all the string theory
papers how much of it has been applied
to condensed matter physics or see even
pure mathematics so it's easy to look
back with hindsight and say oh yes
cryptography yes we use combinatorics
though we thought would never have any
applications from the 1940s and 50s but
then it did yeah okay yeah but you have
a survivorship bias there so you can't
just fund research no matter what
thinking that hopefully it will have
some application because in the past
anything that was a applied was
theoretical before because you have to
look at the other direction too and I
don't know if an analysis that's been
done no so I have no issue whatsoever
with pure math I think that's a very
valuable occupation but you have to
Define your work it's pure math that
that's perfectly fine and then
universities can decide how big the
Departments of pure math would be but
you can't have people that practice pure
math for a century you know which is the
lifetime of a person in the physics so
the question there is a characteristic
time scale if you do pure math let's say
for a decade or two before it actually
is compared to experiments that that was
the traditional practice of physics but
if you do pure math for the entirety of
your career and then we will never know
during your lifetime whether it's
relevant to reality or not I say you
know it's that's what pure math is all
about that you never know how because
even pure pure math in mathematics by
mathematicians is applied eventually
actually in some context of physics
right but the way to Define pure math is
as ideas that are not necessarily
applied uh to the real world and
describe the real world during the
lifetime of the practitioners not
necessarily and there are mathematicians
that invented the mathematical Concepts
that were applied shortly after they
invented them and they were
mathematicians okay so the distinction
is that physics is engaged with reality
through experiments and if there is a
subject on which no experimental data
comes our way for very long time there
are many other subjects that we can work
on doesn't mean that we should insist
working on something that we have no
data on uh perhaps we should wait for
that data in the context of quantum
gravity is waiting for example for
gravitational waves to be detected from
the early universe or learning something
about black hole singularities that we
didn't know about but until that data
comes along we have no guidance and my
point is if you look at a hundred years
back quantum mechanics was discovered by
experiments nobody expected it uh in
fact in around 1900 a very uh famous one
of the most distinguished
experimental physicist Michaelson uh who
actually did the Michaelson Morley
experiment that uh led to Einstein's
special theory referrativity he uh gave
a speech at the inauguration of a
laboratory in Chicago and he said that
from now on you know most of physics is
solved that was 1900 also physics is
solved and the only thing that remains
is
measurements of the fundamental
constants in physics to the sixth
decimal point
and how wrong was he because five years
later Albert Einstein came with special
theory of relativity that that revised
our Notions of space and time then
general theory of relativity that
revised our notion of gravity and then
quantum mechanics a completely
unexpected Discovery okay that reality
is not what we expect from classical
physics just to show you that without
experimental guidance that led to the
birth of quantum mechanics we would
never be there okay and Albert Einstein
argued that quantum mechanics uh perhaps
can be interpreted in the same way as
classical physics but he was wrong Niels
Bohr was right on this and now all the
gadgets that we use you know like these
computers that the two of us are using
to communicate or cell phones it's all
based on quantum mechanics so here is
applied physics a whole industry of
Applied Physics that came out from the
discovery of quantum mechanisms
from experiments and I said what's the
lesson of that that we nature is very
subtle we don't know in advance before
experiments what nature is about
okay and if you don't have guidance by
experiments you may go in the wrong
direction you may go into a dark alley
and to claim that we can come up with a
theory of quantum gravity just based on
pure thought
is arrogant and in fact String Theory
did not come up with very concrete
solutions to the Big Bang to
singularities in black holes over five
decades okay so I say we took that path
it didn't lead to predictions that can
be tested experimentally
and I asked young people do you want to
be engaged in an Endeavor that is part
of course itself part of physics but
does not have any confrontation with
reality I mean you could spend your life
with a notion that is not necessarily
used by Nature okay and there are many
other fundamental questions that we can
address that have experimental tests so
why not engage in those you know they
are huge problems that the society faces
and at the same time as you see that you
know that attitude of saying let's toy
with mathematical ideas that you know
that we can do gymnastics intellectual
gymnastics on at the same time that you
have that as part of the mainstream
simply because there wasn't any
experimental feedback from uh
you know from the superconducting super
collider that was envisioned back in the
1980s but was not funded by Congress as
a result there was no feedback from
experiments so there was this entire
community of theories divorced from
experiments so at the same time that you
see that in the mainstream
you see also resistance
to study
unusual objects that enter the solar
system as if they were artificial like
this is the most mundane simple-minded
common sensical thing and it's a
fraction of the cost as well compared to
how much is spent on theoretical physics
each year let's get to the
the first goal which was the Papua New
Guinea Expedition now let me quickly
summarize to see if I have this correct
NASA was studying the skies and the
reason they do so is partly military so
they study the sky and they look for
well they're looking for threats but
they'll occasionally catch meteorites or
meteors so meteorite is when it hits the
ground a meteor is when it just
disintegrates without hitting the ground
okay and a meteoroid I just looked this
up for meteoroid is when it's it would
have been a meteor but it's not it's
around the same size doesn't even hit
Earth correct yeah uh it's basically an
object an object that collides with the
Earth and burns up in the atmosphere yes
okay so there were 274 or so of these
that were collected across several years
yeah you looked at some of the data and
you saw that the speed of one was
greatly different than the speed of the
rest and greatly different in that it
exceeded the speed of the rest and now
my speed is important is because just
like there's an escape velocity of the
Earth to get out of Earth's orbit
there's an escape velocity of a solar
system which I never considered before
and so if we're thinking of interstellar
objects then it would have to be around
that speed or greater okay so then what
we saw was or what you saw was that
there was
a high-speed meteorite
okay great high-speed meteorite and that
and the speed matters because it tells
you potentially its origin
so that's something that I want to I
kept hearing you bring up speed I'm like
why the heck does speed matter okay so
this is why speed matters yeah because I
just think about if you throw
um a rock up in the air it will fall
back because you don't throw it hard
enough but if NASA launches a spacecraft
and it moves fast enough it will escape
the pool of the earth so speed matters
you need to overcome the the
gravitational potential of the earth
it's sort of like imagine a trampoline
Okay and the Earth is at the center of
the trampoline and it's sort of like a
bowling ball you know it creates a well
and if you want to throw a marble out of
the trampoline you need to throw it at a
high enough speed because otherwise it
will fall back and so there is always an
escape speed above which an object will
escape from the gravitational potential
well of the Earth or of the solar system
in the case of the Sun and and this
object by who way wasn't moving just
fast enough to escape
but it was moving actually outside of
the potential well faster than 95
percent of all the stars it was moving
at 60 kilometers per second outside the
solar system if you extrapolate back in
time so it was really fast
okay and just to get some numbers out of
the way approximately 11 kilometers per
second is Earth's yes and what is the
escape velocity of the solar system
now the solar system is at the location
of the earth it's 42 kilometers per
second it's it's always a square root of
two times the velocity of a circular
orbit around the object that you care
about
if you have okay gravity produced by a
single point mass at the center and
there is a certain speed by which an
object will move in a circular orbit in
the case of the earth is about 30
kilometers per second and therefore the
Escape speed is the speed such as the
kinetic energy will equal the potential
energy and that's a square root of two
faster than the circular speed then
speed square root of 2 times 30 is about
42 kilometers per second so that's the
speed by which an object would move if
it were just to escape from the pool of
the Sun and came from the vicinity of
Earth okay but this object was moving
even faster than that if you I mean it
collided with Earth at 45 kilometers per
second but if you take out the motion of
the Earth because it was it came from
the side so to speak then it actually
moved at 60 kilometers per second
outside the Solace it was really fast
okay and then last question before I get
to someone Skinwalker and ce5 and
unidentified submerged objects and so on
the last question is okay so not only
was this going extremely quickly but
then when you analyzed well what's its
toughness it was twice as tough as the
second highest rock as well okay so it
has unusual characteristics okay now my
question is how the heck do you
find such an object when we can't find
Malaysian Airlines hours after let alone
decades later and it's a larger object
and we had governments involved and we
knew what it looked like and the size
and so on so what does this look like
what is this Papua New Guinea expedition
look like okay so the Malaysian airplane
did not create a fireball it did not
explode so that satellites or
ground-based observatories would see it
in the night sky so all we know about it
is that it moved along a certain path
okay and we don't know at which point
along the path it plunged into the water
okay so then we have a very long path to
study on the opposite floor and the area
that you have to explore is huge so even
though the object is bigger than this
meteor that we're talking about the area
that you need to explore is much much
larger okay and in the case of the
meteor we know where the explosion took
place so we have a square region that we
will study we also know what the wind
speed was at the time of the explosion
what the elevation was and what the
water currents were so we have a model
where we so we can calculate depending
on the fragment size distribution we can
calculate where the small fragments fell
and where the bigger fragments fell and
just it's just like mowing the lawn
basically uh scoop the the thin layer
the top layer of the ocean for any
fragments left and my point is this
meteor was really bright and we know
precisely just think about GPS systems
they can localize your car
in Boston
or in any other City to within a few
meters so imagine you get the GPS
coordinates of your car and then it
explodes okay
so you ask yourself how can I find you
know like if you only knew that the car
moved between New York City and Boston
you know it will be much tougher to find
the car
and suppose it didn't explode it just
went off the road somewhere then it
would take you a lot of time to to find
it and you might not find it but if it
exploded and you had you know like
photographs from satellites of the
Explorer you know the GPS location to
within a few meters it's a piece of cake
to find the fragments so that's the
difference all right let's get to a
question about Jack valet so Jack valet
I saw this video and I'll play it for
the people who are watching right now 20
years ago you know that was a very
marginal idea in science today it's not
such a marginal idea in science if you
look at the sky and Telescope magazine a
year and a half ago published an article
about the creation of universes with
multiple Dimensions moving at life and
go to each other that's a very
interesting idea it's a theory and
perhaps the UFO phenomenon is giving us
the opportunity to test some of those
Advanced theories in physics I think
that's why we should look at it Jacques
says that uaps could potentially be used
to test for alternate universes or
perhaps Dimensions though I think he
says universes
so what's your opinion on this okay so
as a physicist
the standard approach you take when you
examine experimental data is to say you
know we have a standard model of physics
it's uh it's a set of rules and
equations that were tested many times in
many laboratory experiments okay and
that's what we use for technological
development when we develop a cell phone
we base it on the known laws of physics
you know no company would say oh maybe
the quantum mechanics is wrong let's
develop a cell phone based on some idea
about how quantum mechanics may be wrong
or maybe we will build a a cell phone
that operates in other dimensions or
maybe a cell phone that communicates
with another Universe you know no
company would survive if it were to
Advocate that it will build a piece of
Technology based on unknown physics
because it will most of the time you
know almost always be proven wrong like
if this company is successful then they
will get the Nobel Prize because they
discovered that General visit so the
standard approach in doing science or
physics is to adapt what is known as the
standard model of physics and
use it first to interpret any data you
get any experimental evidence so suppose
you include UAP in the unidentified
objects the first approach of the
Galileo project in particular would be
to use the standard laws of you know the
the
standard model of physics to interpret
whatever we see so we have a set of
instruments detecting things we will use
the laws of physics as we know them now
if we see an object behaving in ways
that definitely violate the laws of
physics we will go there but before we
see that there is no reason and moreover
I should say the first thing I would
check if I see something moving let's
say faster than light just as an example
you see a point of light
moving across the sky faster than light
okay and you can in principle infer that
it could be that it's an artifact of the
Optics because there is some reflection
in your detector that moves the point of
light faster than light if you think
that it's far away but in fact it's
moving only within the instrument so
well you know and and it's really
difficult you do a lot of experiments
you don't find deviations so it's not as
if you just see something unusual and
you say okay the laws of physics are
wrong you can't just do that that's
irresponsible you have to
study the whatever you're studying with
the best instruments you have to
understand the instruments you know it
takes a lot of steps and currently the
data on UAP is not good enough it's you
know many of the images are blurry many
of them are based on uh uh you know
amateurs taking the data and so we
really need to go through the scientific
process to validate that there is
something beyond the standard physics
okay but Jacque Valley is mentioning
that as a possibility I say you know
there are many possibilities just like
you know in the context of string theory
there is a possibility that
you know string theories of one type of
another type and of course a lot of
people can
say a lot of possibilities Jacque Valley
may suggest one possibility and then
someone else will suggest another but it
doesn't mean that we need to take it
seriously until there is
data that is validated that is
reproducible that is based on well
understood
Suite of instruments that detects it
okay and so we are not there yet that's
what the Galileo project aims to do and
and if we find that there is no physics
of course that would be extremely
exciting because it should apply to the
rest of the universe not just this
object so suppose you find
uh you know something completely new
that physicists never imagine then it
applies everywhere in the universe and
and that would be of Much More Much
broader consequences because you can
build new devices based on that at that
point
technology development companies in
Silicon Valley could build gadgets that
make use of this knowledge okay so it
would be revolutionary but before we we
claim that we have something
revolutionary we should you know
consider the mundane first
there was a paper published last week by
zeliev and
and petukov and reshetnik about uaps in
Ukraine did you happen to look at this
or are you aware of it
yeah I actually saw it and you know
um
uh obviously Ukraine is currently in a
military conflict and there are lots of
things flying in the sky okay and uh
usually in scientific experiments we
want to minimize the level of noise of
spurious things that may be
misinterpreted so if I were to design a
place where I would search for
unidentified objects
Ukraine would be my last choice because
there would be so much noise you know
and and an experiment usually wants to
maximize the signal to noise ratio so um
I you know I find it surprising that the
paper about unidentified objects would
be written from that location because if
you wanted to study UAP you would go to
a remote site far away
okay speaking of a remote site that may
have plenty of signal rather than noise
what about Skinwalker have you thought
about putting some Observatory at
Skinwalker and if not why not what are
the criteria that you use to select
where to place an observatory
right so the first limitation we are
facing is the level of funding that we
have because at the moment we have one
Suite of instruments that cost me about
250
000 and we're testing it right now and
within a few months hopefully everything
will work and then we will deploy it at
the aside that would allow us to get the
useful data and analyze it so hopefully
by the summer of 2023 uh we'll have the
data that we can share uh with the
public the scientists uh and that will
be peer reviewed in terms of its
interpretation
um but in order for us to build many
more systems like it we need to expand
the funding level of of the Galileo
project at the moment it's only a few
million dollars and in order for us to
expand it by a factor of 10 we need a
few tens of millions of dollars so if we
do get that we will be able to to place
a lot of stations in many locations
including perhaps
Skinwalker I have no in fact it would be
interesting to see if there is anything
unusual there the only locations that
I'm hesitant about are those that may
involve sensitive facilities like
nuclear plants or military bases simply
because of National Security issues so I
don't want
us to
be at risk of violating the law or or
I don't want the intelligence ages is to
worry about the data that we collect so
I want us to do the job of astronomers
you know astronomers have observing
sites in remote locations in places that
are of no National Security risk and I
See This research project as an
astronomy project in fact the
administrator said Harvard asked me is
this part of your day job just as I was
about to establish the Galileo project
and I thought about it for a few hours
and then I said yes it is part of my day
job because in astronomy we use
telescopes to collect data and there is
no lower limit on the distance you know
we study the sun we study meteors we
study asteroids comets so
that's exactly what we do in the gorilla
project we use telescopes collect data
and interpret it so yes it is part of my
day job and Harvard University approved
of that and indeed it's a project
embraced by the university and the other
unusual thing about this project is
usually you have to work really hard to
get funded and in this case it was
individuals that gave me the money
without any fundraising effort on my
behalf which to me illustrates the fact
that the subject is of great interest to
the public it's of great interest to the
government as well
earlier you mentioned trans medium so
then I know you're an astronomer and so
you care about the sky but at some point
do you envision in the future it would
look for
unidentified submerged objects
well if we look at the Horizon you know
and we are near the ocean and definitely
we will be near the ocean in some of our
observations simply because there were a
lot of reports on objects near the ocean
then we will be able to see if they have
anything to do with coming out of the
ocean going back to the ocean or
um you know and and the same is true
about the them coming from outer space I
mean we know that's what meteors do okay
and this meteor that we discussed before
the interstellar meteor was discovered
by missile Warning Systems that the
government employs it was not
necessarily NASA it was Intelligence
agencies that are worried about National
Security that are monitoring any object
entering the sky because they worry
about ballistic missiles and you know
every now and then they see a rock
coming from out there and colliding with
Earth okay so that's called the meteor
and most of these rocks belong to the
solar system uh there are a thousand
times more rocks that belong to the
solar system than rocks that come from
outside the solar system based on the
statistics that we now know about
Interstellar objects so most of the time
you just see rocks from the solar system
these are leftover rocks from the
construction project of planets you know
that early on in the solar system there
were small rocks that came together to
make planets like the Earth and now some
of them are dispersed they are sort of
like Lego pieces that are filling up and
so they hit the Earth every now and then
a big chunk a big rock hit the earth you
know 66 million years ago and killed the
dinosaurs we know that uh the dinosaurs
did not have telescopes uh and they were
not smart enough to worry about the sky
they just ate grass were happy and
thought that they dominate their
environment well guess what they were
wiped out because they didn't have
telescopes and we as the human
civilization we are smarter so we
developed telescos we can look at
near-earth objects that's how omwoman
was discovered it was identified as a
near-air object it was labeled that way
that's why they looked at it and then
they realized wow it moves too fast to
be bound to the Sun so this was an
Interstellar object so um what I'm
trying to say is the government uh you
know monitors the sky that's their day
job they're not doing it for the sake of
science their day job is to monitor the
sky for National Security every now and
then they see a rock entering the
atmosphere and then it turns out that
the first Interstellar meteor was
discovered by those government sensors
you see and uh and and
my point all along was the government
needs to know with very high Precision
how the object moves because they need
to know that if it's a ballistic missile
whether it would hit Boston or
Washington DC they need to know that so
what my colleagues were arguing was oh
the uncertainties in the measurements of
the government are very big and I say no
they cannot be big they cannot afford
that that's their day job and indeed the
government confirmed took three years
for the government to come out with a
letter saying indeed this meteor was at
the 99.99 from outside the solar system
so I never doubted that the fact that
the government has very high Precision
data
and they find these things anecdotally
you know if you ask yourself
what's the you know what would be the
first sign of objects that visit near
Earth from outside the solar system or
objects that collide with Earth or
objects that enter the atmosphere
it's the government that would first
identify them because astronomers focus
on very distant sources of light and
they have narrow fields of view all the
astronomical observatories look at the
small portion of the sky from uh then if
a bird flies above the telescope they
just ignore it
so astronomers would be hard-pressed to
say oh in the survey that they did they
saw an object moving in an unusual way
in the Earth's atmosphere they were just
ignoring they focus on a Galaxy at the
rateship of five or six so
but the military has to monitor those
things because that's their day job and
the intelligence agencies have so it's
completely
natural to expect the government and the
intelligence stations to be the first to
say here are some unusual objects for us
to Monitor and that's what UAP are about
that's what the first Interstellar
meteor is about and you know we should
just be curious and examine those things
do you think that the main reason for
the government not coming forward with
more information on uaps or at least
more high resolution images is because
that it gives away their capabilities in
terms of sensors or is there another
reason like that's one of the reasons
but there may be a nefarious reason I
don't know I think that's uh that's the
main reason that would be my uh I don't
believe in conspiracies
um if I had to guess I would simply say
that they are unsure what the nature of
these objects is so there are two you
know two general possibilities either
they are made by an adversary with
technologies that we never imagined okay
in which case you want to keep
collecting data you don't want to
release what you know uh
in the second possibility you know it
may be of extraterrestrial origin uh and
you say to yourself that's not part of
my day job you know and I don't want to
release the data because it may reveal
our abilities to identify objects like
if it's a high resolution image then Any
Nation worldwide would know that we can
obtain very high resolution images of
this of this quality so you don't you
don't show it publicly okay so I would
say it's more the fact that the
government is not a scientific
organization it's not
interested in
questions that go beyond National
Security the safety of military
personnel so if you see an object that
doesn't belong to that category it's not
part of your job uh and and the second
is uh you know you don't want to reveal
the capabilities you have and then there
is also this um what you mentioned
before there is this stigma uh in
society about discussing such things
because it's being ridiculed okay and
the the data that existed in the past
was perhaps not of high enough quality
so people could not really discuss it
seriously but now we have
instrumentation that is so good that the
government just can't ignore these
objects that's why the subject surfaced
in the past five years I think partly
because the instrumentation that gives
us the data is of high quality so the
government cannot say forget about it
cannot say you know the stigma
should uh
suppress any discussion on this and and
so the the subject is is surfacing up
yet the government cannot release the
the high quality data so I you know it's
just like um the play by Samuel Beckett
you could wait for Godot but you might
wait forever I I don't believe that the
data will be Declassified anytime soon
so we better collect our own data uh
scientists and try to analyze it that's
what the Galileo project is trying
when I think about how would I do the
Galileo project the main hubris Lee the
main problem that I see for analyzing
regular uaps when I say regular I mean
the ones that are in the popular media
and much of the audience is aware of
those types of tic tac types is that
they don't show themselves customarily
it's not repeatable so how and I imagine
that the third phase remember we talked
about these different pillars so first
was Papua New Guinea second was the
James Webb slash the Chilean Observatory
and the third was the Harvard
Observatory I imagine that the third one
is more aligned with the uaps as we
traditionally know them okay so
did you choose to place it at Harvard
simply because well that's what the
funding could provide and you're close
to it or is there some other reason oh
no no it was just just for testing the
equipment and that's just a testing
phase to make sure that it operates and
then within a few months we'll put it in
location that is much better the reason
we just kept it close to home because we
want to make sure that it works
to our specifications uh now I should
make a comment because I wrote an essay
about it in medium by the way every few
days I I write in medium so people who
are interested should check it out yeah
I don't know how you get the time you're
so prolific you do so many podcasts so
many news broadcasts your professor your
chair on top you're running the Galileo
project you do the medium post for me to
write each day
is a laborious excruciating task let
alone to do what else I have to do well
you know it's uh what I do all the time
and your father
yeah but I should say that it's very
rewarding because for example um just
today I was notified that um the Venice
Film Festival will feature
um a competition uh of 23 projects by uh
film students
study uh
um uh film and and and basically created
uh works that were inspired by my book
about omuamua extraterrestrial and uh
that that book was translated to 25
languages including Italian so that's
what inspired this competition and they
selected the top three and they would
feature them at the Excelsior hotel in
Venice Italy on the 3rd of September
this weekend and uh they would like to
ask me questions about my book and about
tomorrow so what I'm trying to say is
that there is a huge Community out there
here you have 23
students of film that worked hard to
make these projects and competed for the
Venice Film Festival I was not even
aware of that and every day I get a huge
number of emails from people who donate
to the gorilla project who are inspired
by at the same time there are of course
people who ridicule and you know just
dismiss the work but you know as long as
you have the right idea that uh to
pursue the truth you know no prison can
confine your passion so to speak and you
know that was the lesson from Nelson
Mandela who for several decades was put
in prison but eventually became the
first black president of South Africa
and so you just have to keep dreaming
and as long as your dream is real
it will eventually materialize and so I
I I feel inspired by the response of
people now what I wanted to mention
about my essay uh it was about the fact
that you know there are two types of
interstellar objects you can imagine
that there are objects that are not
functional anymore for example imagine
New Horizons the spacecraft that we sent
out of the solar system a billion years
from now it will not be functional it
will be just Space trash so you can
imagine Space trash and perhaps the
meteor that collided with Earth in 2014
was just Space trash okay the second
type are objects that are functional
perhaps equipped with artificial
intelligence so they have some
intelligence machine learning
if that's the case for example if you
have an AI
astronaut an AI system that is sentient
you know we are getting close to
producing sentient AI systems perhaps
within the coming decade okay uh so
imagine another civilization that had
the benefit of you know thousands of
more years of Technology development so
they developed these sentient AI systems
and one of them came to visit us or a
few of them and they might be
self-replicating
just like biological systems because
they have 3D printers anyway if the UAP
if let's say one UAP is of that nature
then dealing with it will not be the
same as dealing with a dark matter or
dealing with a planet or dealing with a
star like the sun why because all these
other things are passive physical
objects
that do not have intelligence you know
the the Sun the intelligence the
electron doesn't have so they do
whatever they do you can design a set of
rules or the physical laws that you can
quantify with equations like quantum
mechanics that describe the motion of an
electron that describe the motion of an
atom that describe the motion of a star
but there is no free will associated
with the sentient being there is no
consciousness associated with a sentient
being but if you have a sentient AI
system
it's a different type of object it's an
object responds to the way you behave
just like humans respond to the way you
behave so it's just like dealing with
humans so if you think about it uh if we
were to deal with sentient AI systems
that come from another planet from
another civilization
who would be best equipped to deal with
them would it be physicists
my answer is no because physics are used
to dealing with passive physical
entities
the best
professionals to deal with those things
would be psychologists they're used to
dealing with sentient systems humans
and if the thing about sentient beings
is that they don't always follow what
they don't repeat they they are not
necessarily reproducible they might do
Under the same circumstances different
things they also digest the data of
their encounter with you in a way that
will make the next encounter different
and so it's a completely different
entity Than Physical objects that behave
always following the laws of physics the
same way and they are predictable there
are producible and so forth so my point
is if we have the privilege of
interacting with sentient
AI systems that came from another planet
we have to use a different methodology
than traditional physics
and that touches on the point that you
brought up that's extremely extremely
interesting so how the heck does that
work would we have to invent a
fundamentally different science because
like you mentioned science generally at
least in physics chemistry and so on
it's indifferent what we study now of
course there's the observer effect and
well but that's predictable
mathematically whereas what you're
saying is that if it's sentient maybe
large Trends would be predictable though
there might be but only if
it depends how intelligent the system is
you see because the more intelligent it
is the more complexities the more
difficult it is for us to forecast what
it will do it would look like free will
in a way and the system will do very
different things on different encounters
so I call that in my commentary in my
essay on medium I call it uh
Interstellar
psychology so it's the it's a new field
we're not dealing with humans you know
humans are difficult to forecast and
that's why psychology is a difficult
subject more more difficult than physics
I would argue uh and then if you deal
with the next level you know once we
develop sentient AI systems you know it
will become a new subject of you know in
universities I think there would be new
departments that analyze AI systems
because why would we focus only on
humans if AI systems are more complex we
need a whole new
area of research that tries to interpret
the way AI systems behave now you might
say oh we we constructed those AI
systems out of Hardware right we built
those computers that behave in this way
well we also construct human beings you
know like we give them birth right in
the womb out of a sperm and egg we know
the physical constituents that were put
together to make a human being okay
that's called birth of a human we see it
in hospitals all the time but that
doesn't mean that we understand humans
psychologists have a hard time
understanding even though we know the
material used to make them
that we can understand the emergent
phenomena so we give them names we give
the name of free will to the fact that
we you know we cannot forecast how a
person will behave under some
circumstances we gave this term of
Consciousness so all kinds of emergent
phenomena that are at the abstract level
just the signature of complexity of the
system that you know you can't just
start from the atoms that make the
system and figure out all these emerging
phenomena because the system is very
complex I mean you can do it if you put
two atoms together you can figure out
how the molecule will behave but once
you make a sufficiently complex molecule
even the best computers might not be
able to figure out what what it does and
and you know building up biological
systems is like building a very complex
system that we can't really tell what it
would do under some circumstances and
especially after it's exposed to a lot
of experiences so it's not just nature
it's also nurture so all of these boils
to to the point that you know there
might be new departments in universities
about
analyzing AI systems in the future once
they become sentient and I can imagine
the same with AI systems that came from
other civilizations
I want to read a this is on point I want
to read a quote from your blog it said
most recently Congress expanded the
definition of UAP to include transmedium
objects that are observed to transition
between space and atmosphere and bodies
of water an object means it
quote-unquote whereas a sufficiently
advanced AI device could potentially
become a u in bubbers terminology or
boobers I don't know how to pronounce it
the name so if you don't mind because I
still have other questions like about
ce5 and so the audience would love to
hear about that if you don't mind can
you quickly spell out this distinction
between it versus you yeah so exactly a
century ago 1923 Martin buber a
philosopher and theologian made a
distinction between two interactions
that humans have you can have an
interaction with an object okay like a a
cup of tea or a ball that's a subject
object interaction it's an I eat
interaction it's an interaction with
uh but he also identified another type
of interaction with something that goes
beyond physical objects like an
interaction with a human being
or since he was religious he also
included interaction with God and God
represented the Eternal you uh but even
if you're secular you know you have
interactions with people if you are a
real person and you know that it's
different from an interaction with an
object so buber made a distinction and
that was the foundation for uh you know
many aspects of psycho modern psychology
and philosophy and so forth and he was
an existentialist
one of the founders of existentialism
and and so his Innovation was to this
distinguish between these two
interactions of human and what I said is
that we are used to associating you with
humans but in the future it could be AI
systems that are sufficiently
intelligent that are sent in and
moreover it could rep present our
interaction with
an extraterrestrial astronaut
now is this to suggest that the craft
themselves may be sentient or conscious
and I'm unsure if you make a distinction
between sentience and Consciousness or
if you use those interchangeably oh I to
me it's just um uh you know it's the the
definition is similar to the touring
test okay in the context of computers
the Turing test that was defined you
know about 70 something years ago by
Alan Turing uh is let's let's think
about it on a practical level if you
take a lot of people that interact with
a computer and they cannot tell the
difference between the uh the computer
being a computer you put it behind the
curtain uh they cannot by by conversing
with that computer they can't tell the
difference between the computer or a
person then for all practical methods
you know it's an it's an interaction
with a you not with an it
in my definition I mean echoing what
buber said uh and so uh to me it's all
about the Practical experience of humans
with the system now those things that
come from outer space may be far more
advanced than any AI system we develop
and so they might be even more
sophisticated they might understand us
the way that a biker that goes you know
on the sidewalk understand ants next to
to it to the bike and the Ants may think
oh here is a biker let's think about the
protocol of how to engage with a biker
but the ants would never realize that
the bicare cares less about what they do
and the biker is a much more you know
Superior level of intelligence
so it's possible that we would encounter
something that is far more Superior than
us and it will not be biological because
traveling across distances between stars
is not something that a biological
creature can easily do I mean we were
selected by Natural Evolution to survive
on this rock that we call Earth we were
not selected to survive the Hazardous
conditions of space so so if I had to
imagine I would say the first probes
that we will discover that would be
sentient would be you know made of
electronics Hardware something else that
is not biological because that can
survive long Journeys they would have
the patience for millions of years to
travel they would not they could repair
themselves if hit by cosmic rays or they
can adapt to changing physical
circumstances much more they don't need
food they just need energy that they can
collect from their interaction with
Starlight with with industrial medium
and so forth so anyway my guess is if we
find sentient
Messengers from other civilizations they
would be equipment that is artificial
with artificial intelligence and it may
be superior to us and it will be an
interaction with the you it might even
be interaction with what we may regard
as a Divine entity because in my
way of thinking uh a sufficiently
advanced scientific civilization is a
good approximation to God it can do
magic it may be able to create life in
the laboratory may be able to create a
baby Universe in the laboratory if it
understands quantum gravity so what we
call God in philosophical texts
religious texts might be represented the
best approximation to it might be a far
more advanced scientific Gadget
compared to what we have right now when
we spoke I asked you about ce5 you
remember yeah yes okay so did you have a
chance to look into that
uh yeah I did look at that
um why don't you ask a question then so
for those people who don't know ce5
stands for Close Encounters of the fifth
kind and it's reputedly some technique
it's some method of eliciting contact
between yourself and a craft or yourself
and what's behind the craft either
calling multiple to come or speaking to
them telepathically in some way
the stories are that if one performs ce5
and one is trained in it whatever that
means that one can
call UFOs or uaps
near them so then I was wondering okay
well
that's all anecdotal this Galileo
project sounds like a great way of
testing that because you obviously would
like uaps to show up if you could get
that repeatedly that would be great okay
so what are your thoughts on ce5 and
how the Galileo project may or may not
use it so we get again to the same issue
that you brought up in the context of
Jacque Valley uh what is being com
contemplated here is a deviation from
the standard model of physics you see in
science or physics we usually use
instruments we don't use humans as
detectors why don't we use humans as
detectors because you know humans very
often are hallucinating uh they have
wishful thinking uh and you cannot
always reproduce phenomena with humans
okay and so I mean psychology study
humans but physicists build instruments
that are completely separate from The
Human Experience so that the instruments
will collect quantitative data that is
reproducible that we fully understand
because we build those instruments okay
these are measurement devices you know
you can think of them as clocks rods or
some electronic equipment that records a
physical phenomena in a way that is
reproducible and all of modern physics
the advances that were made by
experiments were based on
instrumentation not in humans testimony
so once again we get to the issue of how
do we proceed in gathering evidence and
the Galileo project follows the
scientific method basically using
instruments not using people now it may
well be the case that people have some
insight into the UAP phenomena from
something that goes beyond the standard
model of physics it cannot be within the
standard model physics because it's not
part of it right now okay a standard
model of physics is a set of laws and
rules and equations that were derived by
collecting a body of evidence that by
using instruments in Laboratories in
experiments and they were never based on
eyewitness testimonies okay so what we
call the standard model of physics is
divorced from
uh reports by humans okay and if we end
up finding through the Galileo project
that humans do play a role
in terms of
the physical evidence that we collect as
I said before that would be
a very revolutionary
change in the way that physics is done
it will change the standard model of
physics because suddenly the human
consciousness has some bearing on what
you find okay and I don't dismiss it
ahead of time I just say we need to be
convinced by the evidence that this is
the case okay now some people would say
in quantum mechanics what humans know
affects
uh the wave function because if we
collect some data about the system it
changes the state of the system that's
true but it's all done mediated through
instrumentation it's not mediated
through humans human knowledge affects
the way we formulate quantum mechanics
that's true but this knowledge the
definition of knowledge is based on
instruments not based on the human body
okay as the detector or the human brain
as the detector so that's a fundamental
difference that you can't use humans as
detectors in the context of I mean all
of physics was designed Based on data
from quantitative data from instruments
so if it turns out that we are missing
something about reality in the context
of the stand model of physics because it
was only based on instruments then that
would be revolutionary but before we get
evidence for that we can't really claim
that so uh you know I don't dismiss it
ahead of time but I would like to see
the evidence from our instruments first
so you know we can potentially find
something like that if we bring in some
humans and see that a phenomena keeps
repeating in a way that it doesn't
without the humans you know that would
tell us yeah that's more in line with
what I was thinking less to just
wholesale believe the reports I meant
hey you have an observer an observatory
here you get some people who
consider themselves to be notable
practitioners of ce5 there's one notable
one in particular his name is Steven
Greer who may be on the podcast at some
point but regardless you get them to say
hey you I mean you get them to show up
and say Hey you say that you
can instigate uaps why don't you go
ahead much like if someone said I can
pray in a super symmetric particle
appears well then you're like okay come
to this particle detector pray do your
business firstly I don't know how you
would even think that you come up with a
supersymmetric particle what is it you
see a flash of light do you think this
but regardless it's the same idea yeah
that would be a viable experiment I'll
be glad to do it
just to check you know why not as I said
before you know we are just students of
nature we shouldn't assume things are
wrong if we have the experimental setup
already built in and someone wants to
come over and do the test we'll do it no
problem
there's also the hasdown lights have you
heard of them and what do you make of
them
that has dahlin lights and I think
Norway or Denmark yeah so um this
belongs to the category of
you know civilians seeing things that
they do not understand and uh it could
be that some of these things are related
to military activities that the
civilians are not aware of or some
natural phenomena in the atmosphere uh
I'm not dismissing any possibility I'm
just saying the evidence is inconclusive
uh it's uh too anecdotal so we just need
to follow the scientific method collect
good data and then we can figure it out
so we can put a suite of instruments in
those locations and see if we if we
detect anything unusual yeah I want to
read another quote from your blog
self-interaction allows for the
possibilities that there are dark atoms
that emit dark radiation and condense
into dark stars and dark planets that
support dark chemistry that lead to Life
as we do not know it in such a case the
answer to fermi's question where is
everybody might be well you're simply
blind to them
so do you consider that there may be
dark matter civilizations and do you
imagine that they would have no clue
about us as well
they might not have and but that's a
long shot because well the popular view
of dark matter is that it has very weak
interactions that's the popular View and
if it has very weak interactions you
can't make atoms of dark matter you
can't make planets of dark matter you
can't make you know chemistry of life as
we don't know it
although it's a possibility you know you
can imagine a whole Dark Sector that is
completely parallel to the ordinary
matter that we have and it just doesn't
interact with anything that is ordinary
to us okay you can imagine that and um
uh that's what I brought up in my essay
and um you know there are possibilities
that we should allow for this is one of
them until we figure out what the dark
matter is another possibility that we
should allow for is
we asked what happened before the Big
Bang you know one possibility is that
imagine a civilization that knows
quantum gravity and can engineer the
birth of a baby Universe in the
laboratory uh so then you ask yourself
what was there before the big bad well
maybe there were some entities in lab
coats you know white lab coats that did
an experiment that created the Big Bang
in the in their laboratory now what
would that be like it's just like you
know us giving birth to babies that grow
up to become adults that give birth to
babies and so forth so in any Universe
like ours there could be intelligent
civilizations that develop the
technology to give birth to baby
universes and you move from one
generation to the next this way that's
just a possibility I'm not saying since
we don't have a theory of quantum
gravity we should at least allow for
that because at the moment we have no
clue as to what happened before the big
back one of the popular ideas that it
came out of nothing out of the vacuum as
a vacuum fluctuation I don't know if
that's more appealing to me uh to say
that our universe is one out of 10 to
the 500 possibilities and we live in it
just because it allows us to exist other
than saying you know this is the kind of
universe that gives birth to
intelligence such that a baby universe
will be born out of it yeah there's
someone named well you know Lee smallen
who has this idea or used to have the
idea that universes are there such that
they maximize the amount of black holes
because black holes are what birth the
universe is and then there's a way of
testing this apparently and then I
wonder if the conditions for black holes
are the same as the conditions for
intelligent life in which case then
that may be an explanation yeah so his
idea was that we don't understand what
happens at the The Singularity of a
black hole so maybe when matter falls to
the singularity of a black or it gives
birth to a new universe and I you know
we don't know that it's the case we
don't know what happens near the
singularity of a black hole it's
completely speculative to argue that out
of the singularity of a black world
comes a whole new universe I'm just
saying that there could be a sort of uh
a reason why you give birth mostly to
universes that allow intelligence to
develop like ah our technological
civilization because then you have a
chance of them coming up with a theory
of quantum gravity such that they
engineer a baby universes once again and
so it's just like natural selection that
selects those types of universes that
allow more and more generations of the
same type of universe to come into
fruition and and it's different from The
View on on black holes in the sense that
you know it gives us an important place
in the universe the black hole case you
just say okay there are these physical
entities that give birth to maybe give
birth to universes that's I would say
that's not so uplifting not inspiring
but if you think that we would one day
engineer the birth of a baby Universe
you know that gives it's sort of like
thinking about yourself as a future
parent you know that gives you a purpose
for Life uh let's develop quantum
gravity so that we can maintain uh the
longevity of more universes like ours uh
it gives you a purpose for life just
knowing that the black hole will give
birth to universes to me quite
depressing if that's the reason speaking
of us from the field or giving birth to
something from the future this eternal
you from boober there's another quote
that I have though I believe this is
someone speaking to you Avi but I'm
quoting it anyway he said if you obvi
find yourself one day holding a piece of
technology so Advanced that so-and-so
you believe it came from another
civilization that experience of awe will
be because you managed an encounter with
the Eternal you in this civilization
that sent to the object your way so this
eternal you I didn't realize at the time
that that was a metaphor for God I
thought that this eternal you was
somehow Eternal as in temporally distant
or like infinite even and that it was
sent from you from the future to the
past so then I was wondering okay is
this obvi speculating on time travel but
anyway given that what are your thoughts
on time travel well okay so first I need
to explain this this quote that you just
read was a response to a commentary that
I wrote just a day before that and that
person read it uh Tony Lux uh the my I
raised the following question I said
suppose
um we find a version 100 of the iPhone
okay and and show it to an entrepreneur
from Silicon Valley would the
entrepreneur feel like Moses felt seeing
the burning bush
uh which was a sense of oh an admiration
uh and in the case of Moses it was The
Burning Bush was a symbol for a Divine
entity
right and so the response was that I
would potentially have the same sense of
all when seeing a high-level
technological device and noticing the
buttons on it uh and the Miracles that
they can perform
um so again it goes to the point that I
brought up before that the sufficiently
advanced scientific civilization may be
a good approximation to God and by the
way this is a way to unify religion and
science it's often thought that religion
and science
do not have any overlap that in fact one
comes at the expense of the other and
many many secular scientists including
Stephen Weinberg the Nobel Laureate
tried to argue that religion is a theme
of the past that we should abundantly
abandon it and bravely
Embrace a universe which has nothing to
do with the Divine entity now I say
wait a minute just you know be a
be a little more patient because if we
do find a civilization that let's say is
a million years ahead of us in
technological development their
Technologies would appear to us as a
good approximation to God and therefore
whatever we assign to a Divine entity in
religious and philosophical texts would
apply to whatever we find from them okay
and so there is a way of unifying
an entity that was part of spiritual
practice an entity that is much more
capable than we are which is pretty much
God you know like something that is
capable of doing things that we cannot
imagine even getting close to
um and associating it with our distant
future like a million years from now a
billion years from now and another
civilization may have arrived at that
future before we did simply because
their star formed billions of years
before the sun that's all so you started
the clock earlier for them and now
you're seeing something that looks just
like a cell phone to a cave dweller okay
and so
it would look like a miracle what if he
said in response that being pretty much
like God is completely different than
being God and the reason is that in
traditional religion God is this eternal
being that was there from the beginning
if there was such a thing as the
quote-unquote beginning and it's not
just to breed life out of inorganic
matter but to breed the universe to
begin with not breed the universe from
Once you already exist within a universe
and create another one but create the
laws and did so out of some semblance of
love and they care for you so let me uh
mention an anecdote one day I saw a
person on the street next to my home my
wife was telling me it might be a
stalker he's looking at our home for
half an hour now
you you became quite well known why
don't you check who this person is so I
went to the street and I asked them
you're brave uh yeah I you know uh what
do I have to lose
um uh I went to the person and I said
why are you looking at our home for so
long
and he said I used to live in that home
50 years ago I was a kid
and my father by the way buried the cat
named tiger in your backyard
and I said well that sounds familiar
because I saw a tombstone with the name
tiger on top of it and I was worried
that there is a tiger buried under it I
didn't know what skeleton might be lying
underneath and now I know it's a cat
from 50 years ago now what's the moral
of this story
if you share some space with someone
else who predated you that someone else
may know more about your backyard than
you know
and therefore you should show respect to
visitors they may know something about
our past that we don't know uh and
that's why you should always welcome
Interstellar visitors and when you say
that you know a Divine entity God knows
much more because it may have existed
forever it what you define as eternity
you know a billion years might be
eternity compared to a century of our
Science and Technology okay so what you
call eternity is a quantitative matter
and given that we you know our
Technologies develop exponential on a
few year time scale you know every few
years we double our computational
capabilities that's more slow you know
we develop technologies that never
existed so just think about it if we
double every two years what would happen
in a million years what would happen in
a billionaires if it's exponential up to
a point you know of course eventually
the laws of physics come to haunt you
but just think about an exponential
curve that has instead of one century
has thousands millions or even billions
of years
of History it would look like it turned
to you because the state that such a
civilization will get to would be so
Advanced that you wouldn't be able to
comprehend it now it might not get there
because it may be short-lived for
example just like now we have virtual
reality machines you know like you hook
yourself to goggles that give you a
sense of virtual reality it's sort of
like being high on drugs you know you're
looking at some reality that doesn't
exist okay and suppose another
civilization got to the point where they
developed these VR goggles and they are
hooked to them they're happy with them
they put them on their face as soon as
they are born and they live in these
virtual realities they will never engage
with us okay that would be a solution to
fermis Paradox why don't we see them
because they're hooked to these goggles
uh but on the other hand if they are
curious about the real world if they
don't talk about mathematical gymnastics
that we talked about before if they're
really hooked to the real world they
explore the real world and they discover
the real world so that they develop
gadgets that travel through Interstellar
space and rich places
then they might look to us
it's a good approximation to go and so
there is this tension between a
civilization closing off engaging in
Wars uh engaging in destructive measures
uh or simply isolating itself from
reality
there is this risk which I'm finding uh
you know in my pursuit of evidence I'm
fighting against but there is a
possibility that our civilization will
get to that
uh sterile endpoint where either it
destroys Itself by Wars or it hooks
itself to some virtual reality okay
there is that danger and if you get
there you will never launch things into
the real space in the suspect so there
is this tension between the finite
lifetime of a technological civilization
and the ability of that Civilization to
launch equipment to space and and I'm
just relying on the hope that there
there was someone out there that didn't
surrender
to the risks of living in virtual
reality didn't surrender to the risk of
pursuing your ego going towards but
actually was curious
about exploring Interstellar space and I
hope that among the tens of billions of
stars there is someone like that by the
way just so that you know uh so far
there were about
140 billion people who ever lived on the
surface of Earth throughout human
history
and there are more stars than that in
the Milky Way galaxy so we have more
than one star per person who ever lived
maybe 10 stars and that gives me hope
I saw when I was researching the Galileo
Project online that Stephen Wolfram is
on The Advisory Board and I'm curious
what does Stephen contribute to what are
his views if you're allowed to reference
them
yeah so there are a number of people who
serve on our Advisory Board and they
provide us with advice and comments and
Stephen is a brilliant
physicist slash computer scientist and
we benefit every now and then from his
advice to the project but he is not
engaged in the day-to-day routine work
that we have uh and there's a number of
other advisors that we have there are
some that are those philanthropic
advisors who contributed funds to the
project you can find them on the website
that there are others that are that
belong to the science Advisory Board and
these are people who did not provide us
with funding but provide us with advice
what about rizwan Burke
it's the same category he actually
um every now and then tries to help also
in terms of approaching other potential
donors and in general he provides advice
and the uh input help to the project
I noticed that I have a question here in
bold about Bruce Fenton and the tech
tits if you don't mind commenting what
are your views on that PDF it's Bruce
Fenton and he had the australasian tech
tits Interstellar object debris
yeah so these tactites are an
interesting puzzle as to what their
origin is but we don't know the answer
and
um you know in principle it's possible
they represent some unusual asteroids
comets or Interstellar objects but um
it's just unclear at the moment I would
say the jury is still out and then we
need more more data so for example if we
examine Interstellar objects like the
meteor that landed near Papua New Guinea
we can tell whether the composition uh
indeed resembles those tactiles or not
Professor what opinion of yours has
changed in the past few months as a
result of the Galileo project
well uh we don't have new data to
provide us with evidence about
unidentified objects or the interstellar
meteor or any more like object but but
the one thing I learned is that there
are lots of curious
people out there within the Galileo
project is a real pleasure and privilege
for me to work with a lot of skillful
individuals that are dedicated to the
projects volunteer the time and
expertise and we are making headways so
I'm very encouraged by that I I don't
take it for granted because these are
people who volunteered I didn't approach
them they came to me we have 800
additional volunteers that we haven't
reviewed yet so we have a hundred people
in the project 800 more who filled up
the form and we are now in the process
of reviewing them and selecting those
that have the expertise that matches our
interests are our needs so all together
along with the Public's response to the
work we do gives me a lot of hope uh and
so every day you know it's just like
swimming in very turbulent Waters there
are people who try to bring you down and
then these are waves that carry you to
the bottom of the ocean but at the same
time every day there are people people
that lift me up and I just need to
average and and the average is very
positive I should say and but what I
find puzzling are those people who try
to sabotage the effort because we are
not taking any funds from existing
projects and we are just pursuing
evidence that's what this that's what
science is supposed to be so anyone
objecting to this approach is objecting
the fundamental principles of science
pioneered by Galileo Galilei yeah that's
why I didn't get why NASA finds it to be
a conflict of interest oh that's
interesting
um they say that since I'm leading the
Galileo project I'm already engaged in
this activity and their committee is
supposed to evaluate whether they should
fund this activity so their argument is
if I were to serve on the committee I
would probably advocate for funding and
that's the conflict of interest because
I may apply for these funds later on
okay uh however if you do for example
consider climate change suppose NASA
established a committee that will study
climate change would they ban people who
are researching climate change from
being on the committee I don't think so
so part of this is uh the stigma that
there is on the subject because they are
not sure whether it's it's worth funding
and then if they were as sure as they
were about studying climate change then
they would allow for me to be on the
committee okay so Professor I'm sure
you've heard of variable light theories
what do you see as their advantage or
disadvantage
um at the moment we don't have uh any
definite evidence for
um anything moving faster than light or
or that the speed of light is variable
of course in principle that could then
change our perspective on The Big Bang
on what happens inside the black hole
and some people suggested that this
could resolve the singularities we have
in Einstein's theory of gravity but at
the moment these are just speculations
we don't have any evidence for that and
the speed of light is significant
because it represents the fastest
speed by which any material particle can
move and so if you change the speed of
light you can change the rate by which
you communicate and obviously you can
change the Horizon out to which you can
see things there's also another theory
called Direct's large number hypothesis
so what are your thoughts on that and
for those who are unfamiliar do you mind
giving a brief overview yeah so in 1937
Paul Dirac made a hypothesis about large
numbers uh he uh observed that you can
make dimensionless combination of some
of the fundamental constants that we
have uh and obtained a very large number
out of them and the uh the question is
whether it means anything and um
um at the moment you know we don't see a
a good reason for these combinations of
numbers to be that large for example
involving Newton's constant which is a
small number and the electron Mass the
electron charge and so forth and the
thing is in the standard model of
particle physics all these constants do
not have an explanation they are just
measured quantities and we don't have an
underlying theory that uh explains those
constants so
we don't know what the origin of the
large numbers is and one possibility is
that we wouldn't exist as intelligent
beings thinking about it uh if these
numbers did not have their values so
some people are thinking about the
Multiverse the idea that there might be
other regions of space and time where
these parameters obtain different values
and the question is whether life
intelligent life could exist there and
in most of them no the answer is no
because for example the universe would
expand too rapidly and you wouldn't be
able to make stars and planets next to
them so that we can have Life as We Know
It This doesn't exclude intelligence
from appearing in other regions with
other constants because you know there
might be other paths to intelligence
that we are not familiar with and so I
would argue that until we have a theory
that explains the constants that we
measure it's premature of us to make
sense of it and so let's just wait
what are the pros and cons of peer
review
uh the importance of peer review is that
your ideas and and the comments are
tested or at least evaluated by other
Professionals in in your field of
expertise so the pro is that um if there
is any mistake or if there is some
Omission it could be pointed out by the
reviewers of the scientific paper that
one is writing the cons are obvious that
sometimes there is a dogma and many of
the mainstream scientists abide by the
dog minus the result they dismiss
Alternatives simply because they feel a
threat to their field of expertise and
many many scientists establish their
self-esteem and their uh stature based
on past knowledge uh things that they
worked on for decades and they
established through their work and if
there is a new statement being made that
could in principle doubt what is being
known or at least suggests that it's
incomplete they feel threatened they
feel their ego feels threatened and as a
result they resist change and that
happened many times in science where
ideas were pushed aside just because
they threatened the dogma and of course
that's the con of peer review however
over time you know if if at least there
is a way to document the findings
other people may look at them later on
and eventually they might Prevail so
um however you know it obviously slows
down the progress of science if every
suggestion is being moderated by the
experts and for that purpose you know
it's possible to have a different scheme
where there is an archive on the
internet where papers are being posted
not necessarily rejected that firsthand
and we do have such an archive but
unfortunately it's also moderated there
are people practitioners of the field
who decide without any peer review
without any back and forth with the
authors they decide if a submission is
worth posting which again is even more
dangerous than peer review because they
don't have to explain it to the authors
so I would argue in favor of having
since you know uh papers on the internet
do not cost money do not cost much
computer
space Power you know in over there in
the cloud that that we will have a
better system where ideas will be uh
exposed to to the community at large
without being blocked by experts I think
that would be the best scheme have you
tried to publish on archive and it was
rejected
well um uh no but there was for example
a submission recently about the Galileo
project where I described the project as
a whole which is a scientific project
and it has been held by the moderators
for almost a month now uh they are not
posting it and I find that strange
because there are lots of papers in fact
on the archive there was recently a
paper
saying that based on a poll a survey of
UK's astronomers that most of them were
motivated to enter astronomy as a result
of being fascinated by science fiction
okay so that paper reporting about the
Paul of UK astronomers that were
fascinated by science fiction is posted
on the same day on the archive whereas
the description of a scientific project
to explore UAP is being moderated for a
month now on the archive and you ask
yourself is there some agenda behind it
or what what could be the reason for
blocking it
now speaking of Dogma
there's a viewer question his name is
clab's Petter and he wants to know what
things in cosmology do we assume are a
true that we can't prove nor disprove
besides
inflation and brains so maybe ads CFT
what are the religious doctrines of
cosmology
so for example uh the Multiverse is an
excellent example of an area in
cosmology that cannot be proven or
disproven because we don't have access
to regions of space and time beyond the
observable volume of the universe light
could not have
gone across a distance greater than the
Horizon
over the time since the big bang and so
there are these I would call
speculations that are regions of space
and time Far Beyond the Horizon that we
can see where conditions are very
different and perhaps the fundamental
constants are different perhaps the laws
of physics are different uh this
discussion of the Multiverse has no is
not substantiated by any evidence and it
it doesn't appear more credible than
philosophy
uh or theology because it has no way of
being disproven uh of course some people
say maybe one day we will come up with a
way to test it fine until that day comes
I don't see it as part of uh falsifiable
physics
um and of course Cosmic inflation is a
paradigm that in principle can be proven
right for example if we find
gravitational waves uh from inflation
that the theory predicts at different
levels depending on the inflaton the the
field that drove inflation so you can
always design models of inflation that
would produce undetectable signals but
in all of them there is some
gravitational wave background and we are
seeking it uh investing millions of
dollars in the search for them I should
say that there is also a way of
disproving the Paradigm of inflation all
together
and the way to do that is to look for a
gravitational wave background of the
type of the cosmic microwave background
we wrote a paper about it just last week
with the uh a postdoc uh named Sunny
blacknosi uh and we basically said that
at the Planck time uh the universe was
immersed in uh a gravitational wave
background just like the cosmic
microwave background but in
gravitational waves because of its very
high temperature close to the plant
temperature now the theory of inflation
says after that Planck time there was a
period where the universe expanded
exponentially or very fast faster than
light and any such background would have
been diluted we wouldn't have it around
today because there was this
immense expansion of the volume of the
universe and therefore inflation
predicts that we won't find any
gravitational wave background at high
frequencies similar to The Cosmic
microwave background of
electromagnetic radiation and if we
search for it and we discussed in this
paper how one can search for it in case
we find it that would disprove that
there was an Epoch of exponential
expansion or inflation or super luminal
faster than light expansion during an
Epoch of cosmic inflation so there is a
way of either proving inflation or
disproving the entire Paradigm just by
searching for gravitational waves so in
a way that's a scientific theory you can
either prove it or disprove it now there
are other aspects of
the early Universe which are also in
principle testable for example imagine a
universe where inflation didn't take
place but there was a bounce the
universe contracted before that and then
there was a bounce
that kind of a theory makes other
predictions that can be tested so all
together you know there are ways to test
what happened around the Big Bang how
but it's very difficult to test what
happens Beyond this the region of space
and time that we can probe right now
thank you and I'll put a link to that
paper in the description so this one is
from a user named mathematical
metaphysics he says I don't know if this
has been asked before but has Avi
experienced any thing close to what's
paranormal
not limited to UFOs
I never had such an experience and
therefore you cannot regard me as an
experiencer
um and moreover I do believe that the
scientific instruments are much more
reliable than humans as detectors so I
don't need to experience it myself all I
want is the for example the Galileo
project instruments to detect an unusual
uh set of data that would indicate an
object that is not naturally uh
in the atmosphere like not a bird not a
bug not a meteor not a thunderstorm and
it's not human-made it's not a drone not
an airplane not a satellite or
anything else of that sort but but it
looks unusual and for me that would be
credible evidence I don't need to
experience it myself except I want to
see the instruments detecting it and
that I think will bring the subject to
the mainstream of science so it will
serve a very important purpose of
validating what experiences
claim uh I don't
have any opinion about the experiences
reported I I don't dismiss them uh I
would like to find
evidence for for whatever they talk
about through scientific instrumentation
because it's not subject
to any biases that humans have
now in this instrumentation do you
happen to have any analysis or people
who are experts on metamaterials and if
not do you plan on getting them in for
the Galileo project
we do have the Gary Nolan as a member of
our research team and if we do find the
materials that are of unusual
composition will definitely bring it to
his attention for example when we scoop
the ocean floor named Papua New Guinea
if we find that the fragments from the
first Interstellar meteor were made of
some very unusual composition will bring
it to the laboratory of Gary Norton for
sure
this question comes from user Swift
wisdom for Avi Professor Gary Nolan
recently gave an interview with Ross
coltart and stated that the phenomenon
is definitely not human and if people
saw the evidence he had seen they would
come to a similar conclusion that the
phenomenon is a non-material form of
Consciousness so what is a non-material
form of Consciousness and what does avi
think of Gary's position now of course
just so that this is clear
I'm reading a quote from someone and I
haven't verified this quote myself so
take this with a grain of salt
so my view of Consciousness is that it's
an emergent phenomena of
the human body the human body is very
complex especially the human brain and I
don't think there is anything beyond
what the the physical uh composition of
the human body is uh so when people die
I I think of it just like unplugging a
computer from the outlet they it stops
operating and
um and then obviously what we call
Consciousness is a result of our brain
being very complex and one way to
demonstrate that is to build a computer
out of Hardware which is just materials
we find around and we put together and
then get to the level of sentient
artificial intelligence systems if the
artificial intelligence system will
behave in a way that resembles a human
uh we could declare it as having
Consciousness and uh I subscribe to the
Turing test in the sense that suppose
out of a thousand people 900 99 of them
would think through a conversation
through interactions with an AI system
would believe that the AI system is a
human without us telling them in advance
that would be good enough as far as I'm
concerned for defining it as sentient
now even if the AI System is using data
sets from the internet to respond
to the human I don't care about it
because maybe the human brain is doing
the same as long as it appears to be
like a human that's all that matters
because we don't know when we interact
with another human we don't know how the
processing is done in the brain of
information and how how Consciousness
comes into play so I would say we should
just compare it to the experience with a
human and if it behaves in a way that is
indistinguishable to 999 people out of a
thousand I would say it's good enough
and at that point you know it would be
sentient and it would be clear that we
constructed this AI system out of
materials so it would make sense to say
the human body is similar it's
constructed of materials and yet it
displays what we call Consciousness or
free will
and that's a signature of very complex
systems complex enough and by the way
the AI system could learn from
experience so you can see it started
just like you give birth to a child and
early on you educate the child so the AI
system could learn from experience
through machine learning and you can
educate it just like you educate a child
so early on it might imitate you but
eventually it will acquire the qualities
of a person an adult that goes into the
world and interacts with the world on
its own and so in that sense I would not
see a difference between a sentient AI
system and humans and and therefore I
would not think that there is a
non-material form of Consciousness and
therefore when seeking uh an explanation
for unidentified objects I would assume
that if they behave as sentient entities
that they are equipped with artificial
intelligence you know that it's just
devices that are even more sophisticated
in the ones we can we will produce in
the next decade and it would be
interesting because it will open a new
frontier of artificial intelligence from
our side interacting with artificial
intelligence from their side
and I call it a i a i interaction which
is a third category that was not
envisioned by the philosopher Martin
buber who talked about an interaction of
a human with an object he called it I
eat interaction or relation
and he distinguished that from an i you
interaction an interaction of a human
with a human or of a human with God
which is the Eternal you and he did not
Envision back a century ago when he
wrote his book I and though in 1923 he
did not Envision a third category which
I think will might come into play with
which is AI interacting with AI which
may reflect our first interaction with
artificial intelligence from an
extraterrestrial origin so I can imagine
universities establishing new
departments instead of a department of
psychology it would be a department of
Interest Stellar psychology meaning
trying to understand sentient beings
which are basically AI systems that were
sent to us from an exoplanet
so what if your wife says to you Avi
just so you know come to this room she
opens the room it's a secret room in
your house cameras and TVs are revealed
then she says I've been appearing to
love you it's all fake I'm hired by the
government after this I will go continue
to show you love in the same way but
just so you know I don't actually feel
it I'm hired we're going to I'm going to
leave this room and everything will go
back to the exact same way it was before
I'll say the exact same words I'll give
the exact same facial expressions and
perform the same Acts
do you still think that the outward
Behavior implies the internal feeling or
do you have objections like hey wife
this is wait a minute this is no longer
authentic I can't continue in the same
way it was before
yeah so definitely the big picture makes
a difference for me because I always
think about the big picture if my wife
would come to me and say that she was
just playing it like an actor that would
make a difference for me it's just like
participating in a play where you play a
role and that role does not represent
you necessarily so yes I would not be in
love with an actor who displays love to
me uh I would prefer to be in love with
a person who lives life
in an authentic way so definitely that
would make a difference and you can
generalize it through experiences we
have and like for example if
the government tricks us to believe in
some notion and it doesn't seem to be
real I would be upset about it and as a
scientist that's why I prefer not to pay
attention to social media
and focus on evidence and facts because
nature in my okay
view is authentic whatever you know when
I jog in the morning when I interact
with nature it always appears to me as
sincere straightforward whereas people
are not always that way they sometimes
have an ulterior motive or a hidden
agenda that's why I prefer to use
instruments to learn about nature
because they don't have a hidden agenda
and they don't have a Prejudice or an
ego associated with them and moreover
you know I prefer to explore the facts
to guide us and just to give you an
example the expedition to Papua New
Guinea was based on three scientific
papers that we published submitted for
publication two of them but one of them
was accepted for publication already and
then
it was featured on NPR and as a result a
few non-scientists people who do not
practice science uh decided to make
some ridiculing comments on Twitter on
this Expedition uh on a superficial
uh
in a superficial Manner and I asked
myself is this really what they pretend
to be because they pretended to protect
science and argue that this Expedition
makes little sense but in fact there are
anti-science because science is about
seeking evidence this Expedition is
funded by private donations it doesn't
take money from any other scientific
project so the only thing you can do if
you are pro-science is to upload that
to to support it and for example if you
look at mainstream
cases of us seeking evidence we looked
for the nature of dark matter in the
form of the lightest supersymmetric
particle by Smashing uh Elementary
particles at very high energies at the
Large Hadron Collider and we haven't
found it okay and so here is an example
for a search that didn't turn out the
way we expected it to be and then a lot
of astronomers are investing many hours
of on the biggest telescopes in the
search for planet nine they haven't
found it okay so why would one ridicule
an expedition that wants to figure out
the composition of the first intestinal
arm meteor which was supported by a
formal letter from the U.S space command
while at the same time supporting a
search for the lightest supersymmetric
particle with the investment of billions
of dollars support the search for planet
nine with the investment of huge
telescope time
why are these different from the search
for the composition of the first
Interstellar meteor that is escaping me
the only way I can understand it is some
people out of jealousy trying to step on
any flower that rises above the grass
level
okay Lastly lastly now if you could run
the archive we spoke about the archive
before or if you could speak to the
moderators who are in charge what would
you say what would you do
regarding the archive I would establish
categories different categories of
research that allow
for
aspects that go beyond the mainstream
beyond the conventional wisdom such that
you know ideas could be floated there
and let natural selection choose which
one is accepted by the mainstream
community so rather than block the
interaction among scientists of course
there should be a certain threshold for
the content you don't want things that
are not scientific but it's you know
above some threshold there should be
pre-exchange of ideas and by
establishing those categories that allow
for that free exchange you could
accelerate the progress of science
because you are not blocking you're not
moderating Innovation
there is no way for us to know in
advance which path leads to the truth
and therefore we should encourage
rethinking the other risk I see is that
by blocking deviations from the beaten
path we are discouraging young people
from thinking independently because
those young Scholars realize that you
know if in order for them to get a job
they need to subscribe to the main theme
in order for them to post their papers
to get their papers published they must
adhere to whatever guidelines they
receive from the senior people and that
to me goes against the spirit of
innovation
in science against the spirit of the
history of science if you look at the
most important Revelations that we had
they came from unexpected directions and
by blocking those we are limiting the
rate of progress in science so instead
of that let's allow uh sort of natural
selection of ideas let's allow the
community to filter out which ideas are
worthwhile and which not and post all of
these suggestions on some categories of
the archive that allow for Innovation
which currently do not exist the way
that I think about this is that if an
open category exists then it would
automatically become labeled as
pseudoscience even if it's not so for
example there's vixra which is the
opposite of archive that has I imagine
valid ideas and then some invalid ones
but almost all are classified as
unscientific and vixra is considered to
be the place where one goes when one
thinks they have a scientific idea but
they actually don't so is there a way
around this stigma
no there should be of course a certain
uh threshold for allowing postings but
that threshold should not be established
but by what is accepted by the
mainstream so in other words if we are
dealing for example with dark matter so
um we should not just post papers that
give
various suggestions for what the Dark
Matter might be but we should also allow
papers that talk about modified gravity
in various forms and not block them and
so um
the way to proceed is to allow a
conversation among professional
scientists so I'm not talking about
allowing you know uh people crackpots
people that you find often on Twitter
people that do not publish in science so
for example one threshold could be that
uh the the
paper needs to be submitted and reviewed
in a respectable publication or
considered at least in a respectable
publication and not being rejected uh
all together because it has no substance
another approach would be to have
um people with established track record
on the archive that do not only publish
uh
unsubstantiated claims but have also
other papers of that belong to the
mainstream so for example if a person
has let's say 90 or 80 percent of of
their posts uh in the mainstream but
then 10 to 20 percent are out of the
mainstream one should allow such a
person to post the out of the mainstream
ideas because the same person is also
contributing to the mainstream so it's
clear that the person is trying to
figure out solutions to some anomalies
by deviating every now and then from the
mainstream so in my mind a certain
percentage should be tolerated let's say
10 20 percent is a very reasonable
portion of a publication record of a
person to be allocated to risky
propositions one should allow for that
and one can establish such a metric and
therefore that would filter out all the
crackpots that would put the older
papers or order postings on on ideas
that are completely unsubstantiated
I imagine that those who are rejecting
on the archive they wouldn't say well
I'm doing so because it's not mainstream
enough they just wouldn't use that word
or justification they would say that
it's unscientific or some other synonym
for unscientific like pseudoscience so I
know that your solution was about
mainstream just like in Venture Capital
Investments I think it does make sense
to allocate let's say between 10 and 30
percent of the resources to risky
propositions and a simple solution in
the context of the archive would be
to allow scientists who publish more
than 70 percent of their papers to allow
them to deviate from the beaten path so
if anyone can produce you know seven or
eight papers that are within the
mainstream every time they post one or
two papers that are out of the
mainstream
then I would allow those people to to to
make these postings I think that would
be a very simple approach to take
because it means that they are thinking
outside the bitten path and uh
creatively and these are people who are
contributing to the mainstream and I
don't think it will be regarded as
unscientific on their behalf uh because
they are doing most of the work in a
scientific fashion so so that's one
solution and of course another way is to
filter in their affiliation the their
current professional uh credentials so
if they went through all the degrees you
know of scientific practice if they have
a PhD they may be a professor in a in in
a university that should lend more
credibility to their discussion because
obviously by practicing science you know
the details you are more alert to all
the nuances and you are more worried
about your scientific stature and
reputation so it would be natural to
provide credit points to those who have
some professional expertise
Professor I just sent a chat what this
chat is are you able to see it
managing a project with more than 100
members
please go ahead read it it's just a
quote that I found inspiring from your
blog and I thought it would be great to
end with it says and I will leave a link
to your medium it says
managing a project with more than 100
members is not trivial I never served as
a marriage counselor but the best advice
I can imagine giving couples is simple
focus on what you agree on and avoid
getting distracted by peripheral
disputes for the Galileo project this
translates to the advice basketball
coaches often give their team members
which is keep your eye on the ball and
ignore the audience there are historic
precedents of communities that were
destroyed by not adhering to the simple
principle like the story of Babel for
which construction was supposedly never
completed because its City members lost
a Common Language the fundamental task
of good leadership is to maintain the
unifying thread within its community
yes
um I rest my case
um the point is that we need to focus on
the goal that all of us believe in in
the case of the Galileo project it's
collecting evidence and I brought Under
the Tent of the Galileo project both
Advocates and Skeptics
for a simple reason
that when the two camps agree on
something I know that the evidence is
strong enough so for example we have
Michael Shermer and he said that if we
find indisputable evidence he would be
glad to write
an essay in his magazine skeptic about
it and I said that's not enough I want
you to change the name of the magazine
from skeptic to believer
what did he say
he laughed
okay we'll hold them to that
thank you Professor I appreciate you
spending so much time with me
thank you for having me it was a real
pleasure
okay well congratulations for sitting
through a three hour
video again it's astounding thank you
for sticking around for so long to find
out more about anything that's mentioned
in the podcast then do click on the
description there are fastidiously time
stamped themes and catalog references if
any are missing just comments in my wife
or I we read each comment so if you say
that hey at this time stamp you said so
and so would be included but it's not
I'll include it
forgive me as I've spent almost all
night editing and I just need to record
this last bit if you'd like to support
the theories of everything podcast then
visit
theoriesofeverything.org that is
theoriesofeverything.org and become a
member if you're currently on the
patreon and you feel like switching
there are several benefits so for
example one you'll get the entire
podcast early sometimes 12 hours to 48
hours early an audio version without
sponsors or ads you'll get a phone
number to text me if you like you can
ask a question for the Curt AMA so the
Kurt ask me any things and I'll be
likely releasing them there first there
will be discounts on Live Events
sometimes even free once we eventually
do start them there's exclusive merch to
be offered there to be purchased only by
members again in the future I have this
idea for a notebook where I'm putting
mathematical quotes and quotes from
physicists and mathematicians and other
spiritual leaders and Consciousness
experts and so on
that serve as inspiration for what
you're writing on that page whether it's
a Daily Journal or just note taking
there's also the eventual theories of
everything book okay it's not simply a
book I'm not interested in writing
novels and so on it's more an inventory
of the different toes explaining the
terminology behind each and relating
them to one another also when you become
a member or if you like you can place a
one-time donation at
theoriesofeverything.org more of the
money actually goes to Kurt Goes To Toe
like I mentioned in the beginning I
imagine that your supporting toe in
order to support toe not support toe
Plus patreon or to support toll plus
some other platform
even YouTube takes a huge cut these
podcasts take a great great deal of
preparation and I wouldn't be able to do
this without your support so thank you
so much there are many many many plans
for the future man okay well I can tell
you some I would like to hire a
full-time editor I'd like to hire a
full-time researcher to help me with
studying for the different toes as well
as to help with the eventual toe manual
there's also plans for different types
of content and different guests and well
that will be announced when it's ready
thank you thank you so much I may be
live streaming right now if you're
interested you can go to toe clipping so
type in toe clippings on YouTube I know
that's abhorrent to most and I think you
should avert your gaze to most of those
thumbnails because well you can imagine
the repugnancy that follows once you
search something like that however that
is the name of a fairly clever name for
the eclipse version of the theories of
everything podcast sometimes people
aren't like you they're not Troopers
they don't have a they don't have the
time to sit through three hours of a
video and then some they want to watch
five minute to ten minute at most maybe
20 minute chunks and those are where the
shareable clips go I also made live
stream there either right now or at some
point or take different guests or other
podcast hosts just if we want to talk
about some topic without much
preparation without feeling the pressure
of it being on the main toe Channel
because I don't want to dilute the
quality of the main toe channel so other
side content will go on the toe
clippings Channel a link to that is also
in the description you can visit there
like I mentioned I may be live streaming
there and we can discuss this episode
together if you like lastly I'm running
a physics contest
it's a Consciousness and physics contest
called Pace one so p-a-c-e so physics
and Consciousness explications number
one because it's the first time there's
a video about that in the description
Brilliance has come on board to sponsor
one thousand dollars to each of the five
winners so that is five thousand dollars
in total distributed among the top five
essentially you create your physics
explainer or Consciousness explainer it
doesn't need to be both if it
incorporates both that's well great but
it doesn't need to there's a distinct
lack of advanced physics and
Consciousness Concepts so if you have an
idea for how to explain let's say mirror
symmetry or some ctmu concept or yosha
box idea of computational Consciousness
slash simulation Consciousness then do
consider making a video and submitting
to that contest okay I think that's
everything thank you so much and again
thank you to the sponsors that's
butcherbox if you want some Quality Meat
butcherbox.com theories if you you would
like to learn some more about math and
physics that's brilliant.org toe thank
you
all right take care last comment thank
you to Boris Costello for creating the
photos on the website he's a talented
photographer and compositor here's his
Instagram instagram.com
galactpick g-a-l-a-c-p-i-c
the upcoming guests are John verviki and
Ian mcgilchrist coming together for
theologution Stephen Greer is coming up
in October Nick Lane is coming up next
to talk about the origins of life being
predicated on metabolism rather than
genes being the precursor to metabolism
Tim Maudlin is coming on to talk about
the interpretations of quantum mechanics
and of course Salvatore Pious is coming
on with Stefan Alexander a string
theorist slash Loop quantum gravity
theorist to talk about quantum gravity
and Salvador pious's ideas embedded in
the UFO patents plenty to look out for